I work have run up good morning and
welcome to planning referrals committee
of mid supper District Council just two
can I first of all remind us of all of
the domestic arrangements for today the
WC is situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs and the lift where
you came in and outside there there's
also cold water is available outside in
the same area in the breakout area if
the fire alarm does sound can you please
leave the meeting room or the council
chamber by following the fire exit signs
and we are asked to gather at Ipswich
Town Football Club on the training pitch
please do not re-enter the building if
that happens until we are told it is
safe to return can I ask a row just to
double-check your mobile phones please
and check now on silent or switched off
there is a tradition if they ring during
the meeting at 10 pounds donations made
to the Chairman's charity I would like
to remind everyone present that this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
Internet and will be capable of being
viewed repeatedly the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make any representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council consented to being filmed and to
the possible use of those images and
sound recordings for webcasting and/or
training purposes the council members of
the public and press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting and
the public and press are not lawfully
excluded and can I just remind members
please and officers to please make sure
that you press the microphone on when
speaking and turn it off when you have
finished there may be some members of
the public here who have not been to
planning referrals meeting before so
just to run you through who's going to
do what I my name is Matthew Hicks I'm
one of the counselors at Mid South
District Council and on my right here we
have the other counselors that will make
the decisions on the applications before
us today at mid Suffolk District Council
if there is an application in your own
ward you may not vote but you may speak
on the application and if that's the
case you sit on the other side where we
have counselor field
who may speak on you can speak on an
application but not vote on an
application in your area on the far
right we have in depressed Philip
Isabelle
Robert Carmichael James Jack wilkinson I
was going to say James Wilkinson and we
have other officers present who are
going to assist us as and when needed
and we have highways here as well too if
needed as well so I think that covers
everyone in the room when it's your turn
to speak if you come to the front row
you'll be caught up and you have three
minutes we have an egg timer and we do
keep to the three minutes please so if
you go over we will have to end that so
please keep to the three minutes so
moving on to the agenda the first item
on the agenda is agenda item number 1 is
apologies for absence please Thank You
chair
we have apologies from councillor gold
council Richardson Council Madison and
councillor Turner thank you very much if
any cancer does come late they may join
in as long as the we haven't actually
started on the item because there's some
we haven't heard from yet okay do we
need to receive any declarations of
pecuniary or non-pecuniary interest by
members yep let's start the do first of
all thank you chair yes I'm vice-chair
of the stone market town council
planning committee and we have
previously discussed item 7b on the
agenda I'm also a member of same
committee and has discuss today I can
answer Carter anyone else yes castle
wall boys okay no other declarations of
interest by members do we have any
decorations of lobbying I think we've
all probably received the same emails on
which item just to be clear yeah
any solution correct good okay so that's
for all of us have we done any other any
decorations of personal site visit by
members
yes the one-inch dough market 7b anyone
else nope as well thank you very much
master Potter ok if we can now move to
agenda item number 5 which is on page 7
of your papers confirmation the minutes
of the meeting that was held on the 12th
of June 2019 starts on page 7 if I just
run through each page there's anything
you're not happy with just put your hand
up page 7 8 9 10 11 and 12 I happy that
I signed those as a true record of the
meeting that agreed agreed
thank you very much I'll do that after
the meeting agenda item number 6 is to
receive notifications and petitions in
accordance with the councilors petition
scheme do we have any please
Thank You chair we don't have a new
petition with regards to this one but we
have one just for reference for members
that weren't on the development control
be committed that there is a petition
regarding the application submission
with DC 1803 1 1 4 which has 164 5
signatures against the application I
believe that it's also in the case
officers were mentioned within the cases
recorded Louis thanks very much ok so we
now move on to agenda item number 7
which is the planning applications
before us and we'll stay in the same
order as within the papers the first
item is DC 1803 double 1 for land
southwest of the main road and summer
ship and they were to Jack phase
Thank You chairman good morning members
members of the public my name's Jack
Wilkinson I'm a principal planner in the
DM service for babe remit Suffolk your
first item is land southwest of Maine
Road and summer ship this item has been
to a member site visit already along
with to further deferrals following
highways considerations the proposal is
a full plans planning application for 42
dwellings together with associated
public open space access roads garage
and car parking this is a duplicate
application to reference 3 1 1 5 DC 18 0
3 1 1 5 which is a twin track
application so the location of the site
is as depicted in Summerson to the
western edge it's a 1.2 1.82 hectare
site on the edge of settlement of a
primary village as shown by the red
outline site location plan as shown on
the screen in terms of the constraints
the site is directly unconstrained
there's nothing on site but there is
quite a bit within the periphery so if I
start at a North about the juvenile
republic's is listed we've also got
dwelling towards the corner here on the
eastern side and that is set within the
main backdrop of summer shrimp village
to the west we have a public
right-of-way
which runs towards the center so you've
effectively got a link between the
countryside and into the center of the
village that runs snug to the southern
boundary of the site but as I've said
the land is largely unconstrained
in terms of emerging policy and
certainly the emerging settlement
boundary for solution we have the pink
outline which is worthwhile noting the
site is set within this area I do stress
that this is emerging and is therefore
of limited weight in terms of services
nearby we've got the community shop in
orange we've got the primary school in
green to the north we have the Duke of
Marlborough set in purple cursor there
we go and we have the Baptist Church in
white as you'll see from the aerial
photo there is established built form
pretty much on three sides so to the
north east and south so as I said at the
start this is a full plan scheme with
detail the access as shown is on two
main road we have an open space segment
at the top and primary and secondary
roads I'll go into the detail of this in
a moment but that is the layout that is
proposed the existing access which shows
the gravel onto the footpath this is a
view north towards the Duke of
Marlborough pub you can see that the
gradient of the land steep and slightly
from the road up to the current stable
and at the minute and south towards the
centre of solution you'll note the again
the gradient of the bank with
agricultural land and an established
hedgerow
so site accurate access and egress as
we've discussed is sufficient
invisibility display in both directions
it goes above and beyond the minimum
spec for the local Highways Authority I
will zoom in on this image but the
yellow highlight is a proposed footpath
all within the red line as you can see
residents would have the option of
walking left out of sight via the yellow
highlighted area again the actual access
the specification and the configuration
of that axis is highways compliant there
are adequate depths indeed widths at the
mouth and indeed the minimum width of
the dual carriageway that goes into site
it's also worth mentioning as well that
opposite so outside of the red line is
an established pedestrian footpath that
leads off further south into the centre
so effectively do have a link between
the west and the east of the site as
mentioned earlier primary road in red
secondary Road in orange
we've got driveways in yellow hopefully
that shows you know the spec of the
access in a sight for all to understand
to the southern area of the site we have
an opening and if you can recall when I
mentioned about the constraints there's
a public right-of-way that runs along
the south and in effect the site would
connect at this point so you have an
opening at the bottom and that would
enable residents to connect to the
public right-of-way that is freely
available this maps quite useful because
it does show you know the options that
residents would have particularly from
the north to reverse through the site
and along the public right-of-way which
is set in
the kind of amber color as it comes up
on the presentation and off into the
center of the village perhaps the most
poignant aspect is the section here
shown in yellow which is effectively to
the eastern side of the site the red
line is set just where the marker is as
you can see on the screen I will zoom in
which hopefully just provides a bit more
detail we have got a more detailed plant
coming up in a moment but it does give
you an idea of the proposed footpath
there is a narrowing section here the
proposal includes highways improvements
all to the specification under 2 7 8
agreement the Highways Act we as the
local planning authority would secure
that through section 106 and that would
come through a discussion with the local
Highways Authority hopefully this image
gives you an idea the footpath shown in
blue and this is all outside of the red
line the highways furniture as shown to
the eastern side you'd also have on the
approach to what is one may describe as
a pinch point dragon teeth to slow down
the traffic and you've also got warning
signs which are shown on that approach
so back to the site we have a designated
area of public open space I think it's
quite important to consider the public
open space where it's actually situated
we go back to the wider mark arguably
the applicants could have cited it you
know off towards the south but I think
where it's at is welcomed because it's
fairly central a to the pub B to the
settlement that is established and
potentially the site if approved I've
just brought up the rest of the red line
there to show you you know the further
extent but I think the position of the
open space is well thought out when your
officers concur just to give you an idea
of the site as existing agricultural
land use for grazing you can see the
gradient facing north on the photo on
the right hand side and we can refer
back to this photo should you need it
we've got two storey units proposed on
this site in detail and I will if I may
skip through some photos and plans
because there are quite a lot of
elevations that have been submitted as
you'd naturally expect with a scheme of
this size but before I do we've got some
landscaping that is proposed as well
towards the west which I'll just go back
as you can see highlighted there's good
hedgerow provision along that western
boundary which would be Hedgehog
friendly along with the highlighted
trees in sight they're not too clear on
that image but hopefully with the
overlays you can understand the planting
that's proposed inclusive of a more
signature tree within the centre of the
open space so into the detail the
palette of materials are welcomed by
offices they are tonal and there's quite
a good mix in terms of brick elevation
rendered elevation along with varying
materials you've got facade buildings
along with detached units and also
bungalow unit it's quite important to
note that as well it does give a good
mix and tenure and that is supported by
the strategic housing office up if at
any point we need to refer back to these
happy to do so
forty-two units with detail brings with
it quite a few plans and the unit's
proposed are welcome
so finally just some images facing south
you'll see the arrow in the bottom
left-hand corner which shows roughly
where the photo is taken from this is a
view facing north
you like the residential unit of
two-story scale and facing north east
so I'll leave you with some kind of
facts and figures I suppose of where we
are with the application it's 42 units
with 15 affordable the density is
acceptable to officers along with the
parking provision both for vehicles and
for cycles there's footpath and public
rights-of-way links with all around good
landscaping and deliverable for plants
your recommendation from officers
subject to the conditions contained
within report is for approval including
the 106 thank you thanks I've just asked
if we could get photos because obviously
we've all had in the papers let's talk
about the house overhanging the road and
we haven't seen any pictures of that so
if we could get if we could try and get
pictures that cause I think that's seems
to be critical to me yeah okay to all
Trump yeah we'll get this okay thank you
and close ask a couple of questions
before we move on you talked about the
warning signs and par they warning signs
that flash who are they literally just
static warning signs they are they just
static and then you talk about
agricultural land but there were horses
on it
I thought forces I thought if there was
a horse I thought course lands for
horses is not agricultural land well was
it just so in terms of agricultural land
if the land is used for grazing those
agricultural as soon as you exercise or
work those horses that then it becomes a
neck wine use to make it clear its
agricultural okay questions from other
members for a haka talk at Casa Guthrie
first we'll work along yes thank you
very much and can the planning officer
just tell us is there an appeal already
on this side in terms of the application
we're here to determine reference
three one one four there's also a twin
tracker application which is identical
to this which is on the reference DC 18
0 3 1 1 5 the SSA is identical the
applicant has submitted an appeal to the
planning inspector under non
determination so it may be worthwhile
having that in mind the supplementary
question is any decision on this
application may have a bearing on the
inspectors decision or not chairman so
as I understand it we don't have a start
date on that appeal yet when we do we'll
need to come in front of members with
that application to get as you will be
aware and they usually a minded to
resolution arguably that will need to be
consistent or one would hope it would be
consistent with whatever happens here
and you know in practical terms during
the course of debate our matron will
cover some of this territory but clearly
you know that that is a and these meant
by the appellant as being in mind
focusing exercise to ensure that a swift
prompt decision-making is not delayed I
think in practical terms we all we would
hope to be consistent with both
decisions Thank You councillor Ebert you
were next
thank you very much chair I've got two
questions if I may firstly if there are
any electric vehicle charging points
within the garages or on the houses next
to the parking spaces and secondly could
you just clarify the paved foot way
around the site so they'll immediately
across the road as a as a is a footpath
or a favorite way and going north at the
site it that's planned to be a paid foot
way that there is coming pop forward as
part of the apt condition but there's no
foot way on the sort of sudden lead lead
to being in the side to the south
could you just clarify those thank you
of course so coming out of the main
access turning left there would be a
pedestrian footpath as part of this
proposal and opposite the site so you
have either two directly opposite and if
you're going right there wouldn't be a
public right-of-way but there will be
one opposite and so on the other side of
the road that extends easy
on the footpaths again yeah it is paved
yes it's a bound footpath maintainable
thank you so in terms of just like see
the cursor it's a comment out of sight
you'll have a pedestrian foot way along
the frontage and opposite over the road
that is established so residents would
have that option and then and on the
frontage there wouldn't be towards the
right-hand side but you have to consider
also that the established footpath over
the road hopefully that answers your
question in terms of charging points
that's something that's not set there's
something that we could perhaps discuss
so now on the motor than it whilst we're
on the subject because clearly I
mentioned during the course of debate
with them public speaking will end up
exploring a little more of this can we
perhaps explain a little bit about
connectivity or do let's do let's do
photographs well we have Google shall we
identify so in essence and without
taking Jack's thunder there is a pinch
point which I think members who
previously considered that committee
will be aware of in part that's because
the road narrows there is no foot way
the list of building I believe overhangs
the highway or B I'll probably stand to
be corrected by the owner and the
question of that extent of connectivity
at the present point in time people
trying to get from one side the village
to the other arguably must have walking
the road so I'll leave the photographs
to Jack Patrick if you can run that up
and down the street so we can get a
little sense of both the buildings and
what foot ways are available so this is
facing west or facing facing north thank
you so effectively running back to the
plan would be a pedestrian footpath
along where the cursor is and you'll see
if I move up excuse me you've got
effectively where the red line would be
and going around the corner you've got
the overhang from the list of building
and you can see the marker there for the
public right-of-way which runs along the
south of the site so this is the very
eastern corner of the application site
if I run round the corner you can see
the footpath which I'll go around to in
a sec that is opposite the site the
existing site frontage
and this is where the pedestrian
footpath proposal was proposed along the
frontage is literally that stretch down
on the right your the stretch all along
there the stretch that is a
consideration is as shown highlighted in
yellow on the old plan is that stretch
that is the stretch this is all outside
of the redline and it runs from the
public right-of-way marker so Sam can I
ask you a question is there there's not
enough width for the pavement or walkway
to have actually been put on the
actually off the road that wasn't
feasible sorry proposal II as part of
the version will be taken up with the
new foot way that's the proposals if if
it was there there was it's quite
difficult really there are two proposals
sorts of week that we considered one was
just marking and actually painting the
foot way or actually having a physical
curb with a foot way surface so it's a
different vertical level and that would
be that we would take some of the verge
as well sorry just one more question so
with the pavement in or the walk where
the foot way whatever we call it what
does that leave in terms of width of the
road from the edge of the walkway to the
overhang because to me that's I know
we're not in debate life except that but
that's quite critical because you know
that is that is what we're getting lots
of emails about about the fact that is
pushing people from the walkway towards
the house so what is that width and what
is the width of a standard lorry as an
example the running length will be 3.5
meters
so that is in between the white line
that we have requested that come forward
that it's pushed further away from the
building and then it would be where the
curb is or the line is for the foot way
you point five thank you
thank you I think some of my questions
may have been partially answered I have
a couple of questions one is the twin
tract application I'm a little bit
confused I've not come across those
before does that mean that each of those
two identical applications is determined
separately so if we determine this one
today there's still the other one that
also has to be determined that's my
first question
my second question has been partially
answered by Sam Harvey because I was
going to ask is the and I'm still not
convinced I'm not exactly clear about
what it is the pedestrian proposed
pedestrian walkway can you just confirm
if it is going to be a full-sized kerb
or just a white line or a lowered kerb
between the pedestrian walkway and the
roadway thank you Thank You chairman so
so in terms of non determination appeal
you have no jurisdiction over the appeal
to decision so there are two so I'm
forgiving I'm old enough to remember
this when it used to be quite a common
thing back in the 1980s the it
effectively allows the developer to go
straight to the Secretary of State for a
decision and take the decision out of
our hands we nevertheless have to
present a case to that appeal and in the
usual way we will come to committee with
a recommendation Albia that would not be
to determine the application but that
would be to present our case and that we
will be have we had we had the decision
before us we would have been minded to
either grant permission refused
permission or do some other permutation
so that's what that is and non
determination but heels are not unusual
the twin-track approach is quite an
aggressive choice on the part of a
developer but it's available so it's not
unlawful to do it and the feature of the
landscape to that extent it is designed
I suppose to represent some sort of
pressure on the planning authority but
it shouldn't professor your reasonable
judgment is that clear enough future
well happily carry on with whatever is
useful about that can you just explain I
mean what implication does it have on us
here today or is having it's been noted
but is it what is the weight that we
should give that if any so I wouldn't
give it any weight I think what you can
take from it is that the appellant is
perfectly intent on pursuing his
proposal to appeal I think you should
therefore take that threat seriously I
think you should therefore ensure that
your decision making here today is
robust so that any minor to
recommendation can be resilient arguably
if you choose to grant permission here
then the opponent is likely to withdraw
his appeal before you even get going if
you choose to do something else then we
will need to make sure that our case is
cogent and clearly evidenced I'm in it
so I'm just going to say that's the case
with any application I mean any
application comes before us so we would
treat in the same manner so it's it
sounds to me is it's the applicant just
trunk put a bit of weight on the
authority and nothing more and some
authorities do not make decisions in a
particularly timely way and from our
point of view we believe we do but
nevertheless it's it's an option on the
part of a developer to press forward by
promising the planning or authority and
whether I think it's a good idea or a
bad thing it's it's it's just a thing
but I would stress you know it makes the
importance of getting your decision
right and Road
and defensible I would say a little more
mind focusing because you can clearly
see the direction of travel that
somebody has here I don't think we need
to dwell on it we can look at who the
applicant is and I mean it's up to them
they can do whatever they like it's
their call not ours let's move on to the
next yes
Casa Nostra I did about the roadway but
I'm still I'm still a bit confused I
understand that the applicant has put an
appeal in for non determination we've
had that before well I don't understand
is the two applications that are
identical are they both an appeal are we
determining one or both of them I that's
what I don't understand I understand
that the appeals system because we've
dealt with that before but I did what I
don't understand is the is the two
identical applications and are they both
that appeal is one appeal are willing to
tell me one or the other
that's been explained quite well explain
there's one application before you today
that's what you need to determine and
there's a separate application running
in parallel which is subject to
appearance so they're separate they're
totally separate we're only looking at
the one before us today that's in the
papers and yeah the roadway can we just
come back to the roadway please a
present the design has been put forward
for a two inch or 15 millimeter curve
but it has been discussed at whether or
not is just a marked foot way rather
than a physical foot way this was
considered that we would look at this
when we get down to the detailed design
two inches of standard curb I have no
idea what the standard curb is for a
rural area it's usually three three
inches 80 ml two inches is acceptable
when there is over running and when this
over runnable but thank you very much
could you
put that picture back up or just explain
to me the ground spit that you said that
you might need to use in your design who
actually owns that and is there any more
availability of the Grouse there and I
do have one other question the at the
moment the grass verge is highway to the
boundary up to the boundary fence and
then the little hedge that's in front of
the property that is on the boundary
line so there is less verge in front of
that property and the other question I
have is you've obviously worked
extremely hard since the last time
between everybody looking at various
things
has it been considered throw this woman
you don't put a footpath fair at all
yeah well when we first did when I did
my first response on this before came to
the committee first time we I only
suggested that the developer and maybe
it looks at something here because it's
the 30 meters stretch that we know
pedestrians use we know that pedestrians
from the development will probably use
rather than using the public
right-of-way that leads around the back
of the village they have an alternative
route which is actually on the
definitive plan and definitive public
right away but we know people will use
this this is why we've requested
something to be looked at here whether
it was a foot way whether it was just a
road narrowing with markings and this is
what we came up with when we were all
out on site watching the traffic and
watching what pedestrians did
was any consideration given to putting
the footpath on the same side as the
overhang yes there was the thing with
that was that there would be a gap in
between where the existing footway is
that's opposite the development there
would be a gap that we wouldn't be able
to put anything in to be able to put up
down to the properties that are the
listed properties that you're on about
also we're going to put something
physical because we would be worried
about the threshold and putting
something physical against the listed
buildings as in it could obviously
affect they don't prove him not that
Mister building has temporary but it was
a case of it was the safest route
because that's where actually we
witnessed quite a few people were
actually walking on the southern side of
the road at the time we were there yeah
castle wall was just a thought I mean I
think a lot of thought has gone into the
design of the foot weighs in and what's
possible there to improve the safety
other's improvements now dependent on
the development or would couldn't be
carried out without the development
the is is the development will bring it
forward if it was a safety scheme that
Suffolk County Council deemed and they'd
use some safety money to put something
forward but there isn't a record of
accidents there where there's got to be
five accidents within a five year period
for us to even consider something and it
would have to be pedestrian related
accidents as well thank you a couple of
questions there's a doubt there are
three photos of the area on the copy of
my submission that I gave to the officer
this morning
justjust I think you've you've partially
looked at the first issue which is the
foot way which is on the opposite side
of the main road to the actual entrance
I wonder if you could make it really
clear where does that end and easy
actually at Road level or is it sitting
up on a bank that's one issue
the second substantive issue really may
is exactly what are we or is the
committee considering as the highways
import there's been a recent letter from
highways which I think suggests that you
need to secure one Isis obligation and
it states we would also expect the
developer to deliver a new off-road
pedestrian link from stocks Hill to the
core of the village through the creation
of a new or amended right of whyyy
I really have to confess on somewhat
unclear whether that is what the
committee is considering to die and if
it is just what is it or whether we're
sticking with the version which was
presented to the previous planning
committee
I think in terms of determination
certainly you have the proposal before
you with regards to the pedestrian
access along the frontage and to the
east a major stretch which we've
discussed I think what may be on the
table as well in terms of the public
right-of-way is a potential reroute and
that would only be if it members deemed
it considerably necessary to the success
of the scheme on that basis the public
right-of-way officer has commented and
we've secured improvements to the
footpath provision at the minute it runs
along the western side and that is
something that we have secured so that
is part of the overall package of a
pedestrian footpath and also the public
right-of-way and the question about the
footpath where that one that you're
looking at now is so as you can see on
the screen by the marker the footpath
that runs opposite the site as divided
by the road finishes at the property
here opposite to give you that context
of linking back to what is effectively
the pinch point areas you may describe
it or the public right-of-way it's
approximately 35 metres from this point
here to where the footpath ends or
starts whichever way you're going thank
you and another 30 metres through the
pinch point obviously is that footpath
at sort of actor Road level grade levels
you will call it or is it up on the bank
sorry which footpath are you referring
listing it tends to increase so at the
at the opening here to the residential
unit it's typically on Road level and
then opposite the site it does increase
in gradient not steeply gradually
there's probably about two feet
showing the actual road on the footpath
itself perhaps higher in places so he
wants to come in to do Thank You general
yeah um
thanks you having yes you'll be clear
actually in the late papers the view of
the Highway Authority is set out are on
page three through to six and I think
the the advice as I see it effectively
is that the footway scheme is not
essential to deliver the permission as
presently framed it's nevertheless
something that's been put to us and we
have considered it so for the purposes
of your consideration this morning it is
a proposal from my point of view members
may choose to instruct officers either
to keep it to remove it or to do any
other permutation in between but what
you'll see in the recommendation Burfoot
at page 3 and h4 effectively sums up the
advice of the Highway Authority to this
morning can I keep going assume the
officers are finished there was a point
which I think I just like to tidy off
with the agenda and if I draw members
attention to page 23 paragraph 3.1 which
is about the principle of development
and we're going to our old friend the
Tilted balance from the end PPF where he
saying that paragraph the paragraph
hundred eleven DS not engaged well
should speaking it ears and i imagine
your next question is so what does that
mean and with that in mind perhaps i can
also take you back to the lake papers
and i don't wish to refer to the ball
pit appeals there if we come to it but
it's that they're only for convenience
at the back of the lake papers on page
41 you'll see an appeal decision for a
single dwelling dealt with by a planning
inspector in october and there's a
single dwelling in willow she meets I
know it's on it's very very own facts
but it's quite useful for the way in
which it describes and deals with this
question of the Tilted balance and if I
can take you to pay
42 and 43 there is an analysis layer by
the inspector which deals with our core
strategy policies cs2 cs1 and h7 and in
essence what you'll see there in
paragraph numbers the inspector notes
that those policies in our core strategy
do not contain provisions setting out
how general housing can be located to
enhance maintain the vitality of small
rural communities and the citizens he's
referring to will Isham but that isn't
applicable across the district so the
inspector having identified that and
that's common ground with officers he
goes in paragraph 10 to analyze that
issue in further detail and ultimately
what he concludes in paragraph 10 is
that the court strategy policies that
you have are not entirely consistent
with the National Planning policy
framework now that there has been I
believe some misunderstanding committee
about the effect of what's known as the
presumption in favor of sustainable
development or officers called the
Tilted balance and that's that's now
basically contained in in paragraph 11 d
of the framework and the inspectors
drawn our attention to that in his
paragraph 11 of his decision and in
essence that engages in two
circumstances one is where you don't
have a land supply and we've all been
there we know what that means for the
most recent iteration of the NPP F
however also engage that where policies
were of a certain vintage or were not
consistent with the core strategy and in
essence that is where we as a district
find ourselves and for that reason the
presumption in favor of sustainable
development is engaged here and so to
that extent my advice to you this
morning is that the core strategy
policies which would seek to protect
rural village sites outside settlement
boundaries has to be given lesser weight
to the need to deliver homes required by
the NPP F allowing for all the other
elements of the presumption in favor of
sustainable development and I won't
rehearse those this decision is also
interesting for one other point which is
its treatment of the emerging joint
local plan we
you can find in paragraph 13 over that
appeal decision now okay this decision
related to will Isham but equally the
JLP
mr. Wilkinson has referred to and indeed
this site is within what would be
proposed for the settlement boundary of
summer show now I acknowledge here now
and you'll be able to refer to online I
believe there are objections to the
drawing of that settlement boundary both
in relation to this site and others
within the village so it is clear that
that is a document that is in draft
however you will see in the middle of 13
that mr. Chamberlin says the emerging
local plan is not at an advanced stage
and could be subject to revision to us
as a document is of limited weight
however the intent of policy LPO one is
of a significant it sets out the
direction of travel and is recognition
that the spatial strategy needs to be
amended so that small settlements like
well Isham can benefit from modest
modest residential development so to
that extent the inspector said he notes
that the JLP is a direction of travel of
the council I think I would draw that to
your attention as a way of considering
it here clearly you have a situation
where our traditional policies to
control development in the countryside
cannot be given and should not be given
full weight nevertheless there is
concern over the proposal within the JLP
but you have to bear in mind that there
will need to be a mechanism that allows
for village housing to take place which
the framework provides for and it is
perfectly foreseeable that this site
being within some missions settlement
boundary it might well and it might not
come forward so um I hope that's not
unduly complicated your analysis and
consideration of the question of a
presumption in favor of sustainable
development I would say that you do have
to give a thought to that the need to
promote housing supply and this question
of principle therefore needs to be taken
in the light at the national policy just
as much as local policies and indeed
given more weight and relative to that
thanks Jim sir cut
sorry I may be a little slow but going
back to hot leave the pathway I'm
confused together which side of a braid
we'll be talking about for what site
with a pathway it's the opposite side of
the road to the house opposite side of
happiness so it's a does that involve
removal of hedgerow is it standardized
with forest and a pathway is if have we
decided whatever not it's going to be
raised or not and also the visibility of
the pedestrians for that pathway
what is invisibility going to be like
for the vehicles to seeing pedestrians
if it is a raised pathway and say a
mobility vehicle comes off but over
pathway what is a provision there -
Ashleigh help assist the person back on
to the path and if they are put off the
path in front of traffic what it's been
like you've heard of a collision
disabilities pause so so I'll leave the
officers but it's going to be probably
two to two inches tall height so it'd be
a matter of getting on not to two inches
the width is standard and there is no
hedgerow removal because it's running
along from what I can see but we'll just
clarify that the proposal put forward at
the moment is two inches or 15 mil
curved face there it's is substandard
width at the moment is only a meter
ideally in Suffolk highways we prefer
1.5 as a minute 1.2 is an absolute
minimum
one meter isn't ideal but it is wide
enough for a mobility scooter or a
single person to walk it is difficult
for a mobility scooter and a person to
and another to pass but there is enough
visibility
it's each end for pedestrians to be able
to see what's using the path we are not
saying any hedgerow to be taken out for
this
Hazell thank you cancer cuts do you want
to come back just going so from my iron
sand face no ability for a pass say a
baby scooter and a pram or there's no
way of a person really be honest pass a
mobility skill without stepping into a
road so if a mobility scooters did say
try to pass somebody and they came off
the curb which does Friedan happen
especially being 2 inches and not very
visible but every just need to be
classified that the minimum required is
normally 1.2 meters in which you
wouldn't be able to get to prams or to
mobility scooters passing anyway this is
1 meter so it's york then it's your
judgement but that's that's what's being
proposed and it meets the criteria the
highways are happy with it but that's
been our judgment call I'm just confused
- I see foam a mobility people should
come off the path being changes and not
being out to get a wheel back on the
path again what is the provision
therefore there is no provision that's
the point it's 1 meter wide you're
required to have 1.2 meters wide and
it's 2 meters tall sorry 2 inches -
exactly 2 inches - so that is that's
what's been proposed and it's that's
what's being proposed so that is there
is there's no other there's no other
options available that is what's being
proposed then it's up to us to discuss
it and decide if that's acceptable okay
so both a bit okay any other questions
before we move on okay so we're gonna
move it oh sorry John yeah councillor
Phillip so it's the return to the
questioning just one other poor question
of how our bodies perhaps I believe this
is an informal one-way system it's just
one carriage way wide bearing in mind
that I don't think you can see one end
of that system from the other end
I wonder if always would explain just
how that would work it's a present time
is an informal
give take so it's an informal priority
system no signage telling anybody what
the giving priority at present there is
subs there are there is 30 meters of
visibility at present the minimum really
should be 43 where if you go to menu for
streets the speeds are low it isn't an
ideal situation but it is a the
visibility is sufficient for the speeds
of the road thank you okay so we're now
going to move on to the speakers first
of all we have the parish council
Peggy Pearson if you'd like to come to
the front please and push the mic and
you have three minutes
solution Parish Council recommend
refusal of this application the
amendments amounts to minor design
modifications and do little to address
the concerns of local residents the
Parish Council had reviewed the
application and proposed highway
improvements at length our key concerns
principally relate to impact on
pedestrian accessibility via the Revere
the proposed public footpath at the main
road Mill Lane pinch point the district
councils reason for deferral was on the
basis that there had been a failure to
demonstrate that the proposal would not
have an adverse impact on highway safety
the officers report incorrectly states
that the proposed pedestrian footpath
provision is an endorsed design response
ensuring future on site owners can
safely access the village we strongly
agree with these comments just strongly
disagree the road is very narrow and
dangerous at this point with the level
of traffic reducing the road to an
informal priority system around a pinch
point of poor visibility is not
conclusive of good design or in the
interests of public and particularly
pedestrian safety there is no
disagreement from the Suffolk County
Council highways officer that the
current design solution of the off-site
highways improvements at this Junction
remains unacceptable the development is
yet to propose unacceptable and you live
or highway improvement design the
national polis the National Planning
policy framework paragraph a hundred and
ten is essential in the consideration of
this case it details the requirement
that applications for development should
one give priority first to pedestrian
and cycle movements both within the
scheme and the neighboring areas to
address the needs of people with
disabilities and reduced mobility in
relation to all of modes of transport
and create places that number three this
is create places that are safe secure
and attractive which minimize the scope
for conflicts between pedestrians
cyclists and vehicles the one meter
width of the foot way is not the suffix
design standard the three minutes is up
so the last sentence place the required
minimum width is 1.8 meters to allow for
full pedestrian access and disability
access thank you very much
do we have any questions for the Parish
Council at this point yep now so mayor
first Nick a second hello can you
confirm can two vehicles pass the pinch
point as it stands at the moment time
thank you thank you
where do the pedestrians go at present
to get from one end of the village to
the pub we dodged in between the
overhanging house and the next house
there's just a little bit that you can
walk under the are under hang and
pushing any of the vehicles on the up
that side of the road will just damage
those properties so at the moment it's
in the road that they walk virtually yes
thank you
any other questions No thank you very
much
Oh Casa Casas you have a question
knowing that we can only go on reports
that go through to a police but is it
known to the parish council has there
been any instances where a being a
difficulty between say a bike and a car
trying to pass has there been any
instances of any pedestrians that may
have been inconvenienced by a car coming
the other way but that may or may not
have been reported to a police report it
to the police there's a lot of swearing
from vehicles if you are walking in the
road particularly if they have to stop
shop you get swung up you get called all
sorts of names you get told to clear off
the path clear off the road they think
they have priority very much yet you
want to come back has it has there been
any threatening language from said
drivers that wave believe a pedestrian I
think I think it's waiting to hear say
that's the problem I mean I think we
yeah I mean we've heard that there is
there is there is some sort of
aggression between each road users and
pedestrians any other questions
no okay thank you very much for that
next up we have Andrew Lachlan who is an
objector and again if you got sparked
and have three minutes
and again if you can keep the three
minutes please all right
at three minutes so it's whenever you
want to start could you put the Google
Earth image back up again yeah they're
with us a sec
yeah we will we won't start the clock
yet thank you I might take us three
minutes ago let's get back onto Google
Earth the internet connection
[Applause]
phrasing
just server is where I actually live at
King's College which is the overhang so
that's very good
it'd be interesting to give me other
direction because I think that's that's
the pervert direction if you won't mind
yeah turn around I think um big clothes
if you wouldn't mind just so we can see
what oh yeah that's lovely thank you
very very much three minutes okay as
residents of summer shoe we are incensed
that a proposal such as slide 21 and 22
and the related lake correspondents
suggests that resolutions of Road Safety
and access issues could be deferred to
an s106 planning obligation we were
grateful for Suffolk highways for
finally acknowledging the risk but
unfortunately that hasn't come across
today who in their right mind would
consider this amendment to put up for a
pathway here as an accept as acceptable
or appropriate to propose a 3.5 metre
wide uncontrolled roadway on a blind
section of highway and to place a 1
metre raised unprotected pathway against
it and to not understand the
implications to heritage assets there's
a suggestion that bollards in the road
would be appropriate What nonsense
bollards would reduce the road with even
further and prevent large agricultural
vehicles and HGVs from passing through
some assume is surrounded by arable
farmland but yet the movement of large
agricultural equipment has not been seen
as relevant or even recognized to not
even consider the impact on the grade 2
listed old post office which is a
scandal and that's just slightly further
on for that on the pinch point it cannot
be protected it doesn't get a mention in
any of the documents produced by the
planning officer it's not even
recognized as at risk by the heritage
officer and that ladies and gentlemen is
not only a disgrace but it typifies the
lackluster approach exhibited by
officers right the way through this
process
how can it be acceptable to remove any
possibility of even maintaining the
listed building it's a tad a nonsense
and it's a dereliction of duty now we're
faced with this deluded expectation that
a suitable pedestrian route can be
secured
through an s106 planning obligation in
october mr. Patman ji was at length to
advise the committee that an existing
1:06 provision would upgrade stocks
he'll public right away a total sum of
eleven thousand five hundred pounds was
in place to upgrade to puppet rice away
stocks Hill is roughly 60 meters long
how much upgrading could be achieved
with five thousand seven hundred and
fifty pounds I would suggest relatively
little certainly not an upgrade to allow
its use by all which was implied by mr.
Patman ji in reality stocks he'll would
remain largely unchanged it is not an
inclusive public right away and
continuing to misrepresent that fact is
a disservice to everyone it's now
suggested that it might be possible
under an s106 obligation it hasn't been
mentioned here today but it was in paper
submitted to upgrade and therefore
utilize the public rights-of-way which
exist above the proposed development
these rights-of-way do not link to the
development they are across arable
farmland which is routinely ploughed the
land is heavy clay and in winter
resembles the song and of course it's
unlit what sustainable upgrading can
possibly be achieved so in conclusion we
suggest that this application should be
rejected as no realistic plan has been
provided that safely gets pedestrians
through the main road pinch point or has
any possibility of meeting the
aspirations of the s106 planning
objective your three minutes is up the
last sentence my last census we said we
sincerely hope this happens he will
prevail thank you very much thank you do
we have any questions please are you the
resident in the overhanging house and
yeah so has been hit by yes by noise
it's been hit by James mr. said last
time James castings father hit it twice
Wow James testes is that a local farmer
he's also a parish council his son's a
district councillor yes and he's his
father when when he was driving a
vehicles through hit it twice we've had
it's been brushed by a bus we've had
paint left on the overhang because a
single decker buses is hit so yes it has
been hit thank you Hey other questions
from members
No thank you very much for thank you we
don't have a supporter but we do have
the African - agent Chris Smith if you'd
like to go up for three minutes please
Thank You chairman members my name's
Chris Smith on development planner for
Hopkins and more following the previous
identification of this site suitability
for housing within the draft local plan
of 2017 we've developed and refined the
proposals now in front of you in
consultation with the offices and the
various statutory console TV police the
development which we feel will be very
much in keeping with the character and
appearance of the village as you've
heard the proposals would deliver a
total of 42 much-needed high-quality new
homes including 15 affordable homes
whilst retaining the vast amount of the
existing trees and landscaping
surrounding the site and the settings of
the historic buildings beyond alongside
the new homes again as you've heard a
new area of public open space will be
provided whilst necessary financial
contributions towards local
infrastructure provision will be secured
by a combination vasila process and a
section 106 agreement as has been the
subject of much discussion this morning
the finer details of the off-site
highway works desired proposed are
clearly still of different opinions as
to how they should take place we've
clearly put forward a scheme as being
presented by your officer that was
originally suggested by Suffolk County
Council highways clearly affect still
appropriate were happy to provide that
equally if alternative proposals are now
considered more acceptable or revisions
to that are considered acceptable by
Suffolk County highways then again we're
happy to to progress those as is
indicated by officer through the through
the continuation of conditions and the
section 106 agreement in summary
therefore we hope that you can convert
concur with your officers recommendation
that the proposals do represent
sustainable development such that you're
able to support the grant of planning
permission thank you I'm happy to answer
any questions thank you would you just
like to explain why you've put two
applications in at the same time there's
been a lot of questions by members on
that yes it has been alluded on
unfortunately um these things do take
time as has been indicated and you'll
see from your report those both
applications have put in some 18 months
ago now
clearly normally applications should be
determined within 13 weeks unfortunately
as you aware we're now at the third
committee for these so obviously in
order to assist with the progression of
the proposal some with we've put into
applications such as that we can look to
potentially get a judgment from the
planning inspector it should jump Matt
let's continue to to take time with this
other application is it a normal
practice of Hopkins and more to do that
or is it just on this application it's
common practice throughout the
development industry as is your officer
is alluded to well it's it's unfortunate
things take time and and you know we
we're here to try and deliver housing as
quickly as we can and if that process
enables us to facilitate that name
clearly ourselves along with other
housing developers looked to utilize
that approach any other questions
Samantha thank you I'd like to ask a
question about your environmental
sustainability because I note that our
officer made a comment that it was
rather vague statement of insufficient
depth and suggests and conditions being
imposed about environmental
sustainability so I just wondered what
sort of environmental sustainability
schemes you might be willing to
incorporate into this development yes I
think initially the initial statement
that went in was opened to two changes
we suggested various things that could
take place since that time we have put
in a more detailed statement that
indicates things like how we'll achieve
a 10% reduction in renewables in use of
renewable not non-renewable sources on
the side so we'll look at things like
heat exchangers possibly solar panels on
properties all things that will help us
achieve that 10% reduction
and and what about electric car vehicle
charging points as was mentioned by my
colleagues it's something that could be
incorporated yes isn't it just standard
now that you just put them in on every
home you build it slightly did become
standard shortly yes I would think yeah
it's not yet it hasn't been to date but
it's something that is is emerging we're
aware of there's obviously increasing
use of electric vehicles and I think
before too long it's thought it'd be
incorporated into building regulations
anyway so it's something it's not need
to happen at castle wall boys carrying
on their sustainability
you mentioned solar panels looking at
the layout of the development
I'd say about less than half the
properties have got south-facing roof so
that puts the rest of the development to
disadvantage when the better graded
fitted passive or photovoltaic cells
gets clear clearly there are a number of
considerations in the design and layout
of the development and it's not possible
to have all the roof folks slope space
indirect itself but clearly there's a
potential to achieve some installations
on there that will we'll be able to use
that approach any other questions
right thank you very much okay now Casa
filled we don't take written submissions
from them from board members who allowed
to speak but we don't take written
submissions so it's over to you I have
checked it if we've never done it before
if we did it was such a dangerous
precedent so thank you don't worry about
that you did last on but some okay I'll
shall read it out I made it a written
submission because there are three
photos on the bottom which sort of
illustrate the width of the brow just to
be clear we've all had those photos
actually from lobbying okay thank you
very much Oh
press on point out I will sort of focus
on the highways issues of this are the
the villages might have a view of the
rest of the development I would
personally don't see the rest of the
issues really is significant it is a
reasonable housing site to my mind so
that's perhaps slightly different to the
residents note that this is the third
meeting about this application and we
have a last appear to have some evidence
of significant effort to clear and clear
application of highway engineering skill
to this we've got a recent letter
however the proposals that now have
represented appear less than clear with
substantial but and it's fine work to be
done under a 106 agreement I feel that
the new proposals for fall short of
those needed to persuade the community
the development is acceptable and to
ensure the requirements of the MPP F are
unmet the community have for many years
being concerned at the hazards that
exist in the area of new line to mine
road junction particularly in front of
Street farm the great to listing Kings
cottage and the pump house
these are pre-existing is
the point of significant safety problems
that limit future residents use of
sustainable means of transport to local
facilities that's the village shop
recreation ground village hall and
primary school while the development
cannot be expected to resolve practice
in issues for existing traffic it should
address the risk to pedestrians from the
proposed gentlemen who wish to walk to
village amenities the latter might
involve 11 journeys for a child and
parent and 11 journeys for a parent
every day in each direction 44 journeys
in total the NPP F para 109 States
development should only be prevented or
refused on highway grounds if there will
be an unacceptable implement on highway
safety or the residual communicative
effects on the road network will be
severe I suggest that the threshold of
the first levels is exceeded the MPP F
also requires development should create
places that are safe secure and
attractive which minimize the scope for
conflicts between pedestrians cyclists
and vehicles now I'll get to the current
proposal I have to say I'm not inclined
short what is before you is it still a
proposal to put footway on on the
right-of-way in place of it and place a
painted foot way on the stops your side
of Main Road and an informal way way
system the painted foot way is 30 meters
long would take 23 seconds of pedestrian
unimpeded by a child or mobility dip it
is to pass at peak times when children
of their parents walk to school vehicles
will be at some 18 seconds apart on
average a 20 mile Arizona enforced by
penny on a pn out cameras to improve a
pedestrian as chance of survival or
would reduce that risk however the
one-way system is informal as drivers
entry in our end those who priority or
not would not be able to see a vehicle
into him from the opposite end it's
difficult to see how we might imagine
that would work the foot way post as
proposed would move traffic towards the
listed buildings which have an overhang
and known to be vulnerable they did to
me appear to be another proposal in the
current letter from highways the one on
the 6th of November it states it is
likely that some form of pedestrian
improvement would be could be delivered
but taking all of the factors into
account it is in our view that
connectivity advantage of the proposed
pedestrian link do not outweigh the
potential disbelief its assigning and
lining improvement delivered by the
developer to highlight the road
narrowing and likelihoods of pedestrian
the carriageway
enhancing the existing warning signs and
carriageway markings could be more
appropriate so it seems to suggest they
doubt that the current scheme their
letter makes an alternative proposal to
discuss through the 106 obligation it
says we would also expect the developer
to deliver a new off-road pedestrian
link from stops hill to the Coralville
village through the creation of a new or
mended public right-of-way in conclusion
I fail to see how the committee to agree
to this proposal unless the new off-road
pedestrian link was clearly detailed and
proven to be deliverable it's possible
that should don't be prohibited until
this route is defined and agreed
practical by all parties then it might
be acceptable but it could easily fall
by the wayside so I still for these
reasons this application
and should be rejected on Highway
Safety's grams thank you very much
any questions for Castlefield yep casa
cotton my body starts to miss now but
say it just occurred to me and I wonder
if you could answer this as summer
shouldn't been approached as we will
have her District Council's to provide
the roadside maintenance of bit of
bushes by communities to allow for that
I did wonder if so does the pathway
significantly improve the access to the
bushes or does it appear a risk and if
it is relying on the communities doing
so and there's not ability to get be
supportive to maintain fees but these
hedge hedgerows with the pathway next to
it is that likely to restrict fee path
even further and therefore possibly clip
the possessions are even further risk
okay
half the road I could have an surpass
that all villages are suffer have been
given the opportunity to come forward
and take part they want to it's their
decision in terms of I'm doing how doing
maintenance and things on the things
there's there's an invitation to all
villages from Suffolk County Council but
I don't know whether this one's come
forward John's you wanna come in I
really don't know to what extent
Congress has been involved in that I do
know that the the hedgerows that you see
at the narrow spiral pink corn or in
private ownership and therefore I would
have thought that is unlikely the parish
council would be maintaining them any
other questions no okay thank you very
much to council the field some members
we've had before us put all the
information we've had we've heard lots
of different views lots of different
input lots of different ideas it's now
up to us to discuss debate and
to a conclusion so who we can count on
new Cassidy Byrne
first off Thank You chair on had
particular to kick off as it were I'm
cut I'm kind of I think with this
application it's awfully obvious a lot
has been done in in the time since the
the previous committee was was looking
at this and a lot of work has been put
into kind of looking at the highways
issues I mean I am very concerned about
the overhanging house but I think that's
it's as they were trying to use this
application to address pre-existing
highways issues which I think the
council feel don't refer to and what we
need to address is actually this
application and how other residents are
going to get to the village and I think
some of them office you can use their
the footway the public right-of-way down
the side of the site and some of them we
use the road and the majority of them
will probably probably drive so at the
moment I'm probably more in favor of it
than not because I think you know we're
seeing a lot of highways work that's
proposed which is a lot more I think
than we see on some applications so I
would be sort of in favor of that one
issue that I would like to see addressed
in the if it if the committee were
minded to approve it is in the
conditions to have a condition about
water usage renewable energy and
electric vehicle charging but I'll leave
it there and wait to see what my
colleagues say thank you Jeff
thank you so much next up count Samantha
thank you chair I I - was going to
suggest that there should be some
condition for environmental
sustainability should this committee be
minded to approve the recommendation
however I'm I'm a bit more in two minds
and than my colleague I'm I'm yet to be
convinced that the highway improved
are an improvement because there is not
clearly an issue for pedestrians to get
around that corner past the house with
the overhanging first floor and yet
there are conflict conflicts between
pedestrians and other road users
it's a narrowing it's not ideal but I
think in fact I'm a little incensed
actually by highways even suggesting a
one meter path which is clearly
inadequate we've been told that at one
point too is sort of the barest minimum
usually acceptable and most footpaths
have to be at least 1.8 meters so that
you can pass a buggy safely the fact
that it is yeah we have the option we
have an option that it was either just a
line painted on the road which means
that the cars would but practically
ignore it anyway or we have a low
two-inch kerb which cars might go over
anyway so I actually think that putting
a white line or this substandard
two-inch curve of a 1 meter path might
the viewer pedestrians into a false
sense of security in which case I don't
believe it's going to be any safer so
I'm I'm in two minds about the
development itself you know it seems
like a part of land which could be
developed and we've been told time and
time again by our officers that we need
to be encouraging development in in
sustainable locations this is within the
village there's a shop there's a school
as a pub so on the face of it it looks
like a reasonable plot to put 42 houses
but I'm just not happy with the so
called highway improvements in fact I'd
almost think I might prefer it if they
weren't there may I just come in okay I
think it's important to note that
actually the original application had no
pavement at all and highways were
totally happy with that but the
committee asked them to go away and come
back with a design so I think we've got
to be very careful that the two previous
pay applications to previous times to
committee
to go away and come back with something
and so now two subs beat led and say
we're hold on is it's just as more to I
know it's the first time we've seen I
think can I just ask actually because I
think that raises a really interesting
point Philip just to talk through what
are the options because actually you
know the first application had no
pavement then they've come back with
subsequent changes I mean what are our
options in terms of as a committee could
we just say it's what's before us with
the with the drawings shown or is it
actually just a blank canvas can you
just run through it
Thank You chairman um yeah I need he's
confusing I accept so what you have as a
proposal to provide a foot way is a
reaction from the developer while and
what was originally on the proposal
knows you say chairman the original
proposition was acceptable to the
highway Authority now that's in no way
to downplay the concerns of the locals
but clearly we are in the territory of
the professional advice we've had which
is that the application without the foot
way would be acceptable
so albeit that it's on the table at the
moment and there is a reaction to what
committee have previously expressed
concerns about clearly you you do have
the opportunity I would say to say we
don't wish to go with that and to
instruct officers to go away and to
remove that and subject to that to
approve the scheme now as you can see
from what's written in the in the
highways advice in lay papers they
consider that the benefits of that
scheme as its presently designed like
members have started to discuss you know
they're not convinced by either and they
they look to an alternative proposal now
the question of what is an appropriate
alternative proposal is an interesting
one councillor field said that what
should be before you is clearly detailed
and proven to be deliverable I'm afraid
I disagree
usually in planning matters where you
look at things such as Grampian
conditions you have to be able to
conclude that it is likely that
something can be delivered and that's a
balance of probability test rather than
a beyond reasonable doubt test that some
works could be undertaken to improve the
situation and I think it's important
that we bear in mind and Jack I don't
get up the plan of the site which has
got the connectivity points to it
because obviously we are dealing with a
pinch point and we do have a situation
where it is presently a fact that
anybody trying to walk between two parts
of the village will resort to the road
so albeit that it's a drawing and it's
not a model of clarity there is a blue
line on that plan which shows connection
from the foot way on the north side of
main road to the south side and through
the development to the footpath at the
southern end this if you can just run
that through so that we can see where
we're talking about so there is a route
that has been discussed which enters the
site here from the public right-of-way
albeit we're talking about improving
that public right-of-way to a standard
which will make it more useable and if
you can carry that on through to the
northern part of the site Jack - so
members are quite clear so we have a
safe and suitable route for pedestrians
and others to travel southwards and
southeast if they were going to the
village shop now can you get up a dinner
whether it's the next slide on a wider
map of the village where the public
rights-of-way network on place I think
it's slide there yes so that's that's
the village width and the green patch
marks are the rights of way now there's
clearly a question of a pinch point that
is not going to go away can you just
highlight how far that pinch point
actually is jack so we're quite clear
what the issue is because it is a short
distraction section of road there
through there and the foot wave resumes
to the southeast where right okay
so what the opportunity you have with
this scheme is to provide an accepting
they would still be a pinch point to
provide connectivity through the estate
through this new development to the
north now I've not been out and visited
the properties but my mind estimation
there are of the order of 25 to
residents residences to the north of the
site and the pub so as as a regular user
of pubs I find that it's sometimes
appropriate to walk to them and if this
is a way of supporting and facilitating
the ongoing use of that facility on foot
from the South I think this might be an
opportunity to do that as well so in
terms of connectivity we are looking at
both the occupiers of this development
and the potential to improve the
situation for residents who would
otherwise continue to do what they've
always done or get in their cars and
that is to resort to the road to connect
between the different parts of the
village so from my point of view there
are benefits for occupiers here there
are benefits to a number of properties
in the locality and indeed the
connections between the two parts of the
village albeit and I'm not gonna get
away from it albeit that there is still
the pinch point and it is still and
walking in the road situation this could
I believe markedly improve the situation
for future occupiers you are not
obligated to pursue the scheme that is
designed before you I believe that you
can instruct officers to go away and to
impose a condition or a section 106 to
secure an alternative improvement to the
rights-of-way network and I believe
that's reasonably achievable in the
manner that's described in what you're a
call from member training as being a
Grampian condition going back to
Grampian Regional Council many many
years ago as long as there is a
reasonable prospect it can be delivered
it does not have to be clearly detailed
before you today all proven to be
deliverable I'm afraid and so to that
extent I hope that clarifies general
yeah Kosovo something councillor Carter
you did sort of stop me in it in the
middle of my my deliberation so I've
sort of lost lost the thread of it but
but as I said I I met to be convinced
that the highways improvements are
improvements I'm not convinced that they
will make it safer for pedestrians the
ward member did mention a
reduce speed limit which I don't believe
is has been mentioned anywhere else in
the papers and and yes I wasn't act
committed be when this came to it before
so I wasn't involved in the I go away
and make some improvements decision
because you know yeah it would be
wonderful if we could have a fully
compliant footpath but we clearly can't
and I think that that is the dilemma
i I may not particularly like the lack
of pedestrian connectivity but I I'm I'm
not convinced that this is actually
going to be any safer and so either we
have the choice of we don't we don't
think it's safe therefore we can't
approve it or we accept the substandard
so-called improvements and I think that
that's the dilemma I'm in in that I
think in a way I want to support this
but I don't like the substandard
improvements casick RC would yes we seem
to continue along the lines of a
misconception that we should protect
pedestrians alongside vehicle access we
are going along they have a one entrance
and entry and we're going despite
haven't the side view barefoot passes we
are deciding we're gonna put people
going in and out just at one point well
we do have the alternative of actually
having a pathway on the internal of the
boundary we've accessed going into V
verge on each side Reverend going across
the right which I would personally
prefer you going again stopping having a
pinch point you are stopping people
going up in a collision with the road
and putting it that way
the current improvements well being one
who actually regularly uses mobility
vehicles you are actually putting it at
a river two inches if somebody did go
off of a curb which being visually it
partially sighted you are likely to miss
gotta miss
a mistake through that from the curb if
his scooter goes off you're not going to
get back on again you're going to be
going at the subside until you get off
it right so you are going to be leaning
in some road towards a vehicle so you're
actually putting yourself more people at
risk of going towards a vehicle then
you're actually keeping them separate
from a vehicle and knowing people's
nature human nature to want to pass each
other you're going to tried to get
somebody with a push with a pram
favoring that side of a path and putting
themselves at the risk again trying to
get past so the current improvements I'd
say are putting people a lot more risk
than any improvements well that might
appear on paper that's got through his
neck thank you very much for that
several things really I've got the
papers from the last time and we had the
suggestion of the foot way coming off
the site onto the prowl and prior to
that I haven't got the other papers but
it wasn't on there initially so we
didn't have that so when it went away
the first time the developer and the
planners came up with the idea of
joining the the the development with the
prowl and they're not that way I have to
say as chair of both of those meetings I
was driven by the members of the
committee who wanted various things put
in place and I think unfortunately John
isn't here but I did scribble on a piece
of paper why can't we get rid of the
foot way so I wasn't actually that
thrilled with the foot way going in
another thing just coming onto this the
double application just sort of lined
you up again a bit sensitive but not
meaning to it was done on the first and
application that happens to work twice
there as well so we did have that issue
there so it's something there and John
mentioned about something about being a
painted foot wave well I think the
explanation was that it was probably
going to
be a race foot way I'm not sure about
the painted line but that's a detail
that can come in there
I am very conscious that what's just
been said about building a footpath on
the inside of the development well
that's fine but the issue where the big
problem is is outside the development so
that wouldn't achieve anything there
because opposite they've got a foot life
just coming I'll come back to that but
the actual development I was very
pleased to hear the ward members saying
that it was reasonably acceptable I
think something along those lines and
looking at it I don't think it's quite
nicely laid out the densities nice
because I think we should be discussing
these things because as there is a
tandem application going forward we need
to make sure that whatever they come up
with that we've got something regarding
the actual development and I think
there's a good mix of properties I think
they're nicely spaced there's nice
gardens so I would be comfortable with
that
I heard what the Planning Office has
said about the the fact that it's next
to the pub that could enhance the usage
of that and that would be useful and I
like the public open space there because
that still kept the openness as a horse
owner myself I'm very disappointed that
you're losing something like this
because it is hard to get something like
this and it's been beautifully kept so
you know I'm really sad if it goes along
those lines I'm a little concerned that
we've got to be mindful of when and if
members want to refuse things and we
haven't we've got a lot of people and I
hear them loud and clear and I have read
every single email that's come in in
depth and I've printed them all off to
make sure I've read them properly and I
understand the concerns I do understand
the concern of the listed building but I
think similar to councillor Mansell if
the foot wave were removed
think that might improve things would be
my view on that but all in all we have
professional advisers and they are
telling us professionally that both
schemes are acceptable the very first
one without a footpath and now the
applicants put this one in if members
are minded to refuse this then I would
suggest we need outside professional
highways and independent assessment on
it because whilst I do appreciate
everybody's concerns that they get abuse
in the road it's not fun
that is not a professional advice these
applicants have barristers solicitors
and planning lawyers behind them and
they go to appeal and week we have to
have professional advice so my view is
I'm more comfortable with it if we knock
the footpath off but if members are
going to refuse it then I think we need
an outside professional judgment on it
thank you very much a castle Norris
Stuart thank you I'm afraid I still have
reservations about this application
minorly relating to the proposed
footpath scheme and the effect on
pedestrian safety the Highways comments
in the table papers at bottom page three
are continuing of debate for do
recognise the adverse factors that would
result from the main road foot ways
scheme that is being proposed
notwithstanding I always comments
earlier
this morning I believe the proposed
footpath would have been better on the
other side of the road it would have
given some protection to the listed
buildings on the apex of the bend and
would have created a better sight line
for vehicles approaching from the
northwest
as the orientation of the bend would
have been more gradual since vehicles
would then be further out to the right
on approaching it I also have
considerable concerns regarding
pedestrian safety in this proposed
scheme as it stands particularly with
only a possibly a two to three inch high
curb on the foot way so all in all I'm
still not totally happy with this
application and I cannot support it as
it stands Thank You councillor Meadows I
think just if you're if you if members
stop thinking about going down the route
of refusal you're going to need planning
reasons not that we just don't like it
because that is not a planning reason so
we're going to have to be very clear to
have absolute clear planning reasons
because this is already going to the
inspector for another with another
application it's exactly the same so
we're going to have to be very clear on
planning reasons not we just don't like
it a councillor mayor thank you there is
already a pinch point that is dangerous
in one of the photographs we were
provided in the lobbying there's a
picture of a lady cowering behind the
building the building has already been
hit two vehicles cannot pass currently
on that pinch point so there is already
an informal system to get round the
pinch point in the proposals we've seen
that signage curbs better control of
that passing have been proposed are they
an improvement we can sit here and argue
that point for days and we probably
won't all agree but I think the
important point is does the proposed
development
have a severe impact on the highways and
I don't think you can argue it has a
severe impact in that people are already
scared people are already having their
buildings hit so I don't think there is
a justification to make that call of a
severe impact I think the development in
itself looks reasonable but with
additional conditions relating to
sustainability I think that needs to be
hardened up considerably I would like to
consider the off road access to the
village to to be developed further
so I'm mindful of approval sorry is that
a proposal to approve happy to propose
that group
to come in just to clarify something
then we'll come on to castle wall boys
next apologies apologies for asking the
question is that presumed with the
footway detail or without counsel I'd
like to see guidance I mean I'm quite
happy to leave that discussion to the
professionals to try and find the most
suitable solution so I don't think it
has any impact on you know is the
development does it have severe impact
and I don't think it does count Schoen
on the same point well I was going to
say I would second it but I would second
it if the footpath was taken out but
that's the proposer has got to think
about that further thanks you having
become presumably have a propose of one
saying within one's own for the two
things two things two things I wouldn't
be comfortable with one is going away
and sorting it out in inverted commas
chairman I think that's quite poison
chalice to take away a zoning officer
you won't get it right for anybody and
secondly yes you obviously need to be on
the same page from our point of view as
officers the improvement has been put to
you as a negotiated in discussed
solution to the issues raised by
committee the county highway authority
advised us it is not necessary and they
don't necessarily prefer it we therefore
do not consider it necessary and if if
Council of Iowa does not wish it to be
perceived we will seek its removal from
the scheme and will not look to include
it as an expectation under the section
106 Jem becomes mayor council Guthrie
over to you and we did we can go we can
have multiple votes on multiple schemes
we it's not a dead you know I mean we've
we're here for the day if we need it so
how would cancel my house you want to
play it to start with do you want to
keep the debate going and then come back
to you but I think if I were on that
corner on a cold February night in the
dark
would be happier if I was on a football
so I'd like to keep in it I first would
that approach and see where the
committee takes that you want to second
it with that approach how sir having him
oh I was just gonna say instead of
having a foot way if the if the road was
just widened up to where the IRA zone
could would that not make it better
could that be done if he could this is
broke baby boy
we've only got I think that's just we've
got a proposed fest let's keep going
along with men's we haven't got a second
it at the moment Casa war boys was next
I think I'm possible might a second that
I think the development is pertinent to
the site it's I do have my reservations
about its sustainability in the layout
but that perhaps could be addressed I
think the chief planning officer
explained very clearly the the need for
connectivity from one end of solution to
the other and this does go some way to
address it but council Norris did also
suggested the footpath could be on the
other side this would move vehicles away
from the building I think there have
been some serious concerns raised about
the chances of the building being struck
and the footpath perhaps the accessor
baiting this making it more likely to
happen because vehicles weaboo move
closer to the building so perhaps there
needs to be some professional advice on
how that could be mitigated but it but I
think has been explained it's very
difficult to find a very concrete reason
for refusing the planning applications
but I do sympathise enormous Lee with
the concerns raised by the village in
particular as those are existing
problems and is already existing
conflicts between pedestrians and
vehicles
I think the existence of a footpath
could reduce that
and the only way we'll get a footpath is
through the development you serve
beginning you may second that you may
not are you sectarian cancel the whole
second so so it's proposed by counsel
Amir seconded by Councillor war boys as
per the recommendations in our papers
we'll keep going
cancer Carter you were next
we void her system but counsel guff
provides external body might be needed
for the advertisements regarding
improvements I minded I purely on a plan
for just houses looks ideal but we've
got to look at residents people living
as well and I'm always minded if
improvements can be made we have a we
have a duty to look at making
improvements we're so yeah I wouldn't be
able to approve unless we did look at
making necessary improvements whether
it's on the other side of a road or
whether it's making on the intern or
what the structure but if we're not
going to be able to do it ourselves
maybe external advisement not just
effective from profession water body but
also from a disability front as well but
looking at what's before us is with the
improvements as laid out by the highways
officers that's what's weird that's
what's been proposing seconds of that
sort will get the first boat just to be
clear so next was council amounts within
cancer go through thank you I first of
all I just like to have some
confirmation as to whether the current
proposal that we are that's being
proposed ii did includes any condition
about environmental sustainability so
once I finished prattling on perhaps
somebody can just confirm whether that
is the case or not and but the more I
think about this proposed footpath for
more worried I am
we know that there is already a problem
that the overhanging listed building has
already been hit this proposal
and actually it's been here
by buses and agricultural vehicles now
although having 42 more houses in summer
shemite you never know improve increase
the bus frequency who knows with the
current climate lovely if it did but I
presume it isn't it's not really going
to increase the number of agricultural
vehicles that are passing through that
pinch point okay during the building
phase there will be some building
lorries going through the pinch point so
during the building phase the building
will be more likely to be hit as it is
now if we put a footpath in and and push
the traffic closer to that listed
building overhang I think it will be
more likely to be hit so and I am not
convinced that a 1 meter wide footpath
is gonna make people might feel safer
but I don't think they will be safer so
I don't think I can support this with
the 1 meter side footpath but I would
still like to know if we've got the
environmental sustainability in yeah
certainly we can include sustainability
improvement subject to condition that is
an addition that we could rightly add on
prior to commencement including the
electric charging and the water point
that counsel even raised earlier yeah
but that's Carson are you happy with
that
absolutely yeah that's all boys you
second that you're happy with those
additions yeah yeah can I just correct
place your understanding councillor
Cantor the only reason I would ask for
external highways is if it was going for
a refusal and it is not to ask them to
redesign the site it is only is this
acceptable because highways have said
it's acceptable the public are saying
they don't like it they're unhappy
they're uncomfortable and we need if we
go for a refusal a professional outside
advice it is not to redesign this or do
anything else at all with it and the
effect of the pavement on the other side
of the road we have that twice before
and I think you remember we were told
buying I ways that that wasn't
and I think she also alluded to it this
morning
so I just wanted to make that quite
clear that we were not going to outside
highways experts just because okay so at
the moment we have no one else that
wants to speak so I think we're going to
vote on what's been proposed so far
counselor had him sorry can I just ask
one thing for clarity so that the
footpath they're not going to get any
more of the birds they're just going to
use the road that's they're just so
clear what we're voting on please Jack
if you could get the the the specific
drawing out that will be appreciated
okay can I also ask for some clarity I
mean in fairness I'm getting a little
forget although there was a point about
water and conditions which passed me by
I've got sustainability improvements
including electric vehicle challenge
water usage thank you so effectively
recycling measures such as that Thank
You councillor so just while we wait for
that nope
so the question the questions aren't
saying we want to clarify what the
improvements were that are yes
right so so let's let's get this Google
Streetview up and just find the drawing
in your papers 897 so page 97 of your
papers shows the scheme and you'll see
there on the right hand side you've got
the finger post for the footpath and
heading off towards the site which is
over your right shoulder you'll then
have an area of Verge which appears to
be in front of a wall I believe and then
there's an area of hedge see what you
move forward with that Jack fence so you
have a small area verge and then you
have an area of hedge close up to the
road if you look at the drawing on page
97 which is the detail which has been
scrutinized by Highways colleagues you
will see that there is a yellow bar on
that and this is the area of the foot
way that is being proposed and you will
see on that as well within the grey
lines there is also to the south of that
some hedging so the foot way that is
proposed in this drawing butts up
against that hedge approximately where
Jack is highlighting and continues and
it does if you can give us a view of the
verge looking back on ourselves perhaps
that we use subjective just roll forward
and turn around so effectively you are
do you are largely developing within the
carriageway and as you'll see it runs
substantially off within that within the
tarmacked area all the way to the entry
point over the foot way and I know I'll
say it again as as you have in the
advice from County colleagues they don't
consider that there the potential
benefits of this outweigh the issues
that it might raise so that's the
proposition page 97 is the technical
detail which underpins it and as I say I
think that's that's much like actually
yes just be clear that has been proposed
by cancer mayor secular Borough Council
all boys with the addition of renewable
the water and the electric charging
points added in all those in favor the
recommendation has read out can we have
a show of hands please
yeah so that was failed okay
those against okay so then I present
then I propose that we go to a proposal
and a seconder without the improvements
to the highway is that what is going to
come up next cancer gutter is first or
then customer well I'm happy to propose
that with that the it's not without my
ways improvements but without the
football without the footpath is up yeah
but the proud improvements to be
retained and then all the other extra
things that councillor Mansell and
council met yeah happy to support that
as long as we get signage there's no
signage at the moment so there are
improvements can be made
other than okay so it's a first it's
gonna clarify so just just to clarify
then and picking up on page four of your
late papers the top paragraph of the
advice receive from County highways
talks about a reduced signing and lining
improvement delivered by the developer
to higher light road narrowing and
likelihood of pedestrians in the
carriage on enhancing existing warning
signs on carriageway markings could be
more appropriate so those are the things
that we would expect to include in a
section 106 to secure highway off site
highway improvements so those are the
elements which I would put to councillor
gath'ring counts the mayor as being part
of this amended proposition basis we
have proposed from counselor Guthrie and
secular council mayor Councillor carton
cancer masters do you want to come in
I'm almost gonna second that but it's a
wooden time so we do need to look at
some provision to improve so the signage
would be necessary and to apologize to
counter after me I was just I was
understood what she was saying I was
just trying to allude to us why I might
refuse and what I would suggest as it
stands
yeah okay make as I stand so I'd be
happy to support to be as long as we
have the improvements and the
sustainability yeah I think I'm happier
with this proposal and we do need to
signage the road markings the road
narrows so yeah but I just wondering if
we can put any informative on to make it
a 2020 area don't know what the process
is because I'm not sure they have the
same legal standing as a 30 mile an hour
limit anyway but is that an option we
have talked about in beforehand putting
a an informative about possibly looking
it at into that and I wonder whether we
could put that I think we could ask Ann
Saphir just the county councillor who
would have to sponsor that cacica I was
skilled I can certainly try and
encourage that it's possible to process
there is a process for putting twenty
mile an hour speed limits in it's not
one that succeeds very frequently but
it's well worth a try
could I take this opportunity of asking
a question I realize I can't take part
in the debate there is a highway sing
that says we would expect to develop the
developer to deliver new off-road
pedestrian link bloody well are you
including that in this around the back
yes you know something like that sourced
as long as it's not being precluded
yeah so sorry so so at the moment
there's not a substantive proposal for
that but effectively what I'm looking
for is
and authority to negotiate those
improvements or in in lieu of them a
contribution to enable their achievement
if they're not wholly within the
ownership or control okay
so that's been proposed by now by
councillor Guthrie second by councillor
mayor we've heard the what's being
proposed we've also heard the addition
of the three renewable water and
electric points have been added to that
and including the footpath to make sure
that's to include a game around the back
and all those in favor of that
recommendation place eight eight eight
eight those against so it is approved on
that basis what I propose to do is to
take a quick 10-minute break and start
again at eleven forty please thank you
you
just sing casick art is able to continue
or not he's not feeling a hundred
percent so we're just well it's just
going to check that out quickly
[Laughter]
anyway mines chocolate by the way junk
you
right we're back again thanks for coming
back and John feels not cross though to
outside the room so thank you and next
application force is DC 1901 for a tool
and to the east and west of Prentiss
Road and stow market m2 Bradley to
present Thank You chair good morning
members this is an application full
application for the erection of ninety
three apartments and a care home on land
Prentiss Road stock markets this slide
shows the site and also its location in
relation to the general area stock
market as you can see it's between the
railway line which you can see on your
on the to the right there of that slide
and obviously you've got navigation
approach road there and another
distributive row giving way here and the
main body of stow market away on that
side these slightly showed slide shows
the constraints which is the listed
buildings you see the green one is the
church which is grade one the two yellow
and sorry the yellow ones and red ones
are great too great to start you'll also
note hopefully although it is fairly
small scale the extent of the
conservation area which falls includes
the building that's on site directly to
the north the constraints map to is
important to consider because that shows
the site the majority of it within flood
zone two with an areas you'd expect
towards the edgeware with the Gipping
River within flood zone three
that is a more detailed plan which is
zooming in on the bulk of the site which
shows the lines of flooding that relate
to that particular site this is a wider
shop which gives you more of an idea of
the site in relation to its surroundings
and then zooming in a key element to
point out there is the car park that
serves the station and obviously you
will note the title net grain of the
town itself where as you get to the
periphery it becomes more looser where
you find more industrial uses and that
gives you the overall site HD read which
includes land that's to the north which
is highway land and the applicant has
served notice on the highway authority
this is a design of the proposed care
homes you can see it's contemporary
architectural approach but using
traditional traditional materials brick
and render four storeys in height very
modern approach to the design and
similarly with the proposed apartments
contemporary architectural approaches
taken this is the larger of the two
apartment blocks which reaches an
overall height of six storeys that's the
South elevation which would face across
navigation approach and the North
elevation which are faced back into the
site you will notice from both of those
two slides I've just shown the stilts
that the building is on which is a
design response to the issue of
potential flooding on the site and again
there's some views of the smaller
apartment block which would contain 38
units
this gives you earth plan or the-- the
arrangement of the sites of the care
home proposed care home is in this
location the larger of the if I flick to
the next size probably clearer care home
large of the apartment blocks to the
south and the smaller of the appear the
apartment blocks on that particular part
and / Prentiss robe which comes all the
way down finishes at hammer head
approximate at this point this is a
typical floor plan of the care home and
this is a typical floor plan for the
apartment block the reason I've included
this is that you know features such as
balconies which face out across the
river in order to provide some sort of
overlook the view from that particular
point and that's a typical floor plan of
the smaller one this is a useful plan as
a view as it gives you an idea of the
relevant heights
in relation to one of the main views
into the site you'll see that we're on
navigation approach and that is a six
story element but as you climb up that
going northeast you will see that there
the height of that means that the
overall height of the building is in our
terms at least quite a manageable new
piece of built form in that location
this is a view looking down Prentiss
Road with the larger office sorry
residential block in the middle distance
and then to the right hand side is the
care home and to the left hand side is a
smaller primer problem there's a larger
view of the building this is another one
of the courtyard which would be created
by the three groups and as you'll see
the care home is on your left this plan
is put in as it gives a detail of the
proposed link which is a requirement
coming out of the stock market area
action plan which provides a footpath
link from the existing Riverwalk here
across the site and through to Prentiss
Road the final details of that the
landscaping would be a matter to be
considered through condition excuse me
this is a tree protection plan and on
this that would be the case that some
trees along the boundary would have to
come out they're shown as the Peck lines
to the north and in because it would be
a phased development three trees that
the south would come out when this
particular phase of the development took
place it's important to note that since
the submission of the application the
positions of these buildings have
changed in order to try to address
concerns about tree removal specifically
from Stowe market society and pickle
project and that's allowed more trees to
be retained on that side this is an
aerial view taken from a drone which
give you some sort of context again in
relation to the two sites the reason
that's included because it gives you an
idea of contemporary architectural
approach which has been taken
immediately north so there is some
context for the architectural approach
that's being used that building is also
within the conservation area the
conservation area boundary finishes on
that front facade these are some of the
trees on that boundary or trees talking
about some of which would come out as a
result in some of which would be
retained none of them are of particular
value in terms of their Borah cultural
health if that's the right word and
that's been considered by our our board
cultural officer as well but as I say
we've sought to all that the applicant
certainly sought to retain as many of
those as possible
this is another view of the site looking
south towards the bridge the footbridge
which was putting at the same time the
navigation approach was built and
another view as you can see still it's
being used as a car park at the present
time the site of the smaller building
he's overgrown has not been used for a
number of years clearly and he's got
various bits and pieces on it and some
scrub layer this is a view looking
across to the bridge the bridge itself
and the reason I put this in is it
allows views of give members an idea of
the the footpath that goes along the
river at the moment that's looking north
with the trees we've been talking out on
talking about the right-hand side and
this is the existing footpath that all
this would tie into which goes under
navigation approach at present time
there's no a view of the footpath and
more that link that's the footpath link
leading up to Prentiss Road a longer
view of the trees again
sorry if I just go back to that one that
is useful because that gives you an idea
again of the the level of the site in
relation to the level of the road to the
south so you can see there's a there
isn't a pressure will drop at that point
and that's Prentiss Road local car park
that's obviously popular Brazilian
people using its the station you don't
want to use the car park that's there
it's completely unrestricted at this
point in time one of the requirements as
you have noted from my report is that
were this to go ahead the traffic
regulation order would be requested in
order to stop parking down that road
it's more views of that there are
traditional buildings in the in the
vicinity and as I've included this
specifically because it gives you an
order of the juxtaposition of older
listed these are listed grote listed
buildings and the newest stuff directly
adjacent this is the public house on the
corner one of the elements of this
development which which would be
required would as required by the
Highway Authority would be a slight
increase in the width of the path at
this point and a reorganization of the
junction in order that priority traffic
was moving in and out the junction which
isn't the case at the moment and that's
something that Highway Authority have
agreed they've also agreed
excuse me to footpath provision and
crossing points along Prentiss Road
that's a few across from the public
house on your right as well and you can
see the contemporary building in the
back so what you're being asked to
consider today we're taking that gap
there in a town scope
and this is a view from where navigation
approach meters meet skipping way to
give you an idea what that how well
discrete how well the site's screened at
the moment albeit that this group of
trees here wouldn't be lost they're
being retained some of these trees along
this boundary would be lost in the
second phase but not all of them and
again that's another view from
navigation approach and I'll leave you
with that
aerial view site before I finished my
presentation just a couple of points I'd
like to pick up in relation to your
texts on page 161 or more of your papers
the recommendation
it should read 18 months as opposed to
one year that's but they're in error
this that's we're suggesting a limited
time of 18 months from implementation
rather than the Year section 2.4 and
page 1 5 2 there is an error on the
number of car parking spaces
it should read 93 number car parking
spaces for the apartments and 24 for the
care I'm and I know that you've also had
a paper circulated which is the second
response from the pickerel project which
wasn't unfortunately included in the
first bundle the other thing I would say
is that on page 149 the strategic
housing comment it does refer to further
comments being made available at the
meeting we haven't received any more
comments so that's just to clarify that
point thank you much questions I've got
a bunch I could get going first
so use chain that's privative and I
talked about car parking
it's please something and so the
application is 493 residential
apartments yeah and they're now 93
parking places so that's below the
minimum standard required by self a
parking guide and there's no talk about
visitor car parking and then in the care
home there's how many beds in Macomb did
we say seventy seventy-five so for a
care home is seventy five people how
many staff would you have and is 23 or
24 car parking spaces enough for
visitors staff because that doesn't meet
the design guide either so can we just
talk us through that the parking
standard that's been adopted is less
than the standard the max or the
normally applicable standard that you'd
find in in developments the reason for
that is twofold firstly in the stock
market area action plan under the
relevant policy five point six or seven
I think is it does recognize that this
site the station quarter site could
accept a lesser amount of parking
because of its location in relation to
the station buses footpath network
things like that he's a sustainable
location and that is reflected in an
adopted policy the the other thing is
that the adopted standard your adopted
standards do recognize that in urban
areas a lesser standard can be provided
where it's agreed between the highway
authority and the planning authority so
those two things in mind we felt that in
this case it was appropriate to go for a
lesser standard in terms of the amount
of spaces if the full amount of spaces
were apply
to the care home it would you'd require
49 in this 24 in the case of the
residential development if the maximum
Stan will apply for the mix it would be
130 and there's 93 so that's that's the
difference but as I say I think that we
were comfortable with the amount of car
parking based on the policy driver and
the location thank you
yep we'll start down this end welcome
yup can someone at first
Thank You chair basically I was going to
raise exactly the same issue that you
yourself of a chair I have very serious
concerns that there are no visits to car
parking spaces here I welcome a travel
order along Prentiss Road because that
is actually horrendous that's that's
straying into debate questions at this
point yet it was purely basically same
issue debating about the lack of
patience casts the field okay a couple
of things for planning application these
are multi-story buildings that I have
sprinkler provision there anymore in for
town and various areas of that nature so
are we making those provisions
I noticed you talk about a gas works so
it is that being checked for
contamination because gas works were a
place where they produced contamination
by the shed load the issue of flooding
the flats are on stilts the care home is
not that old people can swim better or
is there some other good reason and yes
indeed testing but I will leave that to
you yeah so let's try and answer some of
those questions if not we've got the
applicant here who can probably answer
Thank You chair the the issue of
sprinkling provision sprinkler provision
I think you said counselor I think it
was mentioned in the consultation
response we received
the fire brigade there is normally an
issue that's addressed through Building
Regulations
certainly the apt couldn't be aware of
that because I think the fire brigade
copy their comments directly to the
applicant I'm not sure it's something we
compel the applicant to provide through
planning but I'll take advice on that
with regard to the gasworks element of
it this is the site that does expect
where it's expected that contamination
will be found because of the former uses
so therefore there's a requirement that
any found contamination is mitigated
properly and that would be a conditional
requirement if you're money to accept
them accept the recommendation the issue
of the stilts versus the care home the
care home is on a part of the site where
the level of the water doesn't actually
get above - you saw a slab level than
you saw actual ground level so the
predictive flooding for that part of the
site is different to the bit at the
bottom hence the difference in approach
has been used
Thank You councillor Mansell did you
want to come back yeah John just a
wonderful wonder whether we could ask
the developer who's clearly sprinkled
over colonies not in the building
regulations as we know it relies on
compartmentalization councillor Manso
thank you
alongside the comments from highways
regarding car parking I think there's
also a comment about psycho storage
facilities so I'd like to know if they
do meet the highway requirement for
psycho storage and I'd also like to on
the subjects of cycling the end of
Prentice road on your photograph had a
cycleway sign and it's a link I think
there is a link cycle wailing from the
end of Prentice Road to the tarmac bit
of the river path that goes under the
bridge now that path is not shown on any
of the plans in my pack so I would just
like some come from
that that cycle link from prentice road
to the river path underpass thing is
still there and it's not encroached by
the proposed work that's one lot of
questions about cycling the other
question I had was about the history of
the site because I'm not convinced it's
complete I remember during my first term
as a counselor that we had a planning
application here for a hotel and that
doesn't seem to be mentioned has that
lapsed what what is the state of that
one funnily enough that came off in the
Chairman's brief because I also thought
I remembered the same thing as he can't
sir go through but yeah just on the
planning history I do apologize and
oddly enough I remember it because I was
the case officer for that particular
case now ultimately that was a hybrid
application which had a hotel and a
residential scheme although the
residential scheme was partly on the
ground floor as well as guaranteeing in
that particular case that has elapsed
that wasn't implemented so time has gone
by and so that is material as in his
planning history and I apologize it
wasn't in your papers but it has elapsed
in terms of it's not an implementable
scheme at this time now that obviously
came forward because that was part of
the allocation under the stone market
area to plan and just to touch on that
as well because it's an allocation
within your adopted local plan as part
of the area action plan that is why the
sequential test is different in the
context that he applied to the
allocation so we are looking at a scheme
that is within the flood plain in part
which is unusual but it's actually in
accordance to the regulations that we
have because of his allocation within
the local plan so this is an unusual
site in that context not only as that is
also the middle of stone market but is
that sufficient on that issue you don't
pick up the other points then thank you
yes with regard to cycling provision the
plan does show that there would be an
area for the care home that would
contain cycles so its planned for that
the standard that would be required your
adopted sirness for five
it's proposed in the plan to provide ten
so there's more provision for cycling in
the care home it's above the standard
with regard to cycling for the
residential element of it I've
calculated there's an overall need four
hundred and eighty six spaces now in the
design and access statement companies
are planning on location it does say
that they would provide storage so
therefore I don't see that there will be
any issue with providing that number of
spaces over over the cross the site in
accordance with our standard there's
areas within the building itself at
ground level for example where you've
got stairwells and things like that
we externally you could get I think
spaces in that there's also sufficient
space on the periphery of the buildings
in order to do that as well but that
could that's a conditional where it
could be a conditional record if you saw
with there is no with regard to the the
the footpaths and cycleway then the
actual network that seen there at the
moment is unaffected by the development
the only thing that would be added to is
the link across from Prentiss Road to
the Riverside but that wouldn't be a
cycle and foot way that would be a foot
way only so you'd have to dismount and
push a bike across the site itself but
the actual network to the bottom and
whatever where the bridge is as we saw
in the photograph that be unchanged can
I just so the the residential units the
requirement is 186 space it cycles basis
now that is secured under cover parking
spaces is that the requirement or are
you just talking about putting some bike
racks on the outside it's that 186 186
storage for the residents to put their
bikes away securely under cover or it
does that 186 open space enough for the
purposes of the the residential standard
relation to cycling has to be secured
and covered councillor Carter you are
next yes I don't suppose officers in the
company are aware of the house no market
have a recent environmental forum where
we have passed that we need to increase
our tree coverage by 6% of 6% below
whether or not the project which we are
looking for sponsors of this priority
bill to buy more trees and whether or
not the developers would look into that
but they're slightly off topic but as
Canosa girl asked has there been a
fisherman thought into providing the
electric charges for vehicles in for the
parking and sustainability whether or
not we're likely to be solar panels on
top of their buildings and adjustments
for that as is quite prevalent for the
local area for that said the organs to
have soda pound some salt
the it's clear from the outset of the
formation of this application
pre-submission
that the issue of sustainability was
considered right from the outset and I
think that's reflected in the
consultation response we received from
the sustainability officer which is in
your bundle there's a number of issues
that include the amount of water that's
potable water that's produced per unit
the issue of sustainable construction
I think there's issues around get the
other one you mentioned but that they
are covered within the requirements of
the build and would be reflected in the
development and again one of the
suggested conditions if you're minded to
allow this would be that what is
actually stated in the supporting
information in relation to
sustainability is reflected in the build
itself
I think that my knowledge of the
sustainability officers view of this was
that he was you know quite pleased to
see this be considered and right yeah
and if you look at the page of top page
of once to the top of page 162 bullet
point for sustainable construction of
course with submission design and access
statement but then below you've gotten
the following informative note soondae
or su support for spendable development
principles than that
okay keep working it on category who
next I'm very quickly following on from
councillor Mansell and end up briefing I
did mention that I didn't specifically
see the conditions for the cycle units
but it did just trigger my mind a
storage and cycle perhaps a cycle
recharging point that came up at one of
our meetings just thought I'd mention it
might be useful for some of the bikes
that are now electric well it's just if
it's a cycle point for the before the
care home for the visitors at 100 and
whatever and the other thing was oh oh
yes can you explain the fordable houses
as well I think yes this application has
was accompanied by a violet II
assessment which has been considered by
independently on behalf of the council
as as you have noted from the the report
there's a number of elements that would
be neat needed to be secured through Syl
and on top of that and the abnormals
arising from the redevelopment of the
site it was agreed that the viability
didn't stretch to the provision of
affordable housing on the site so I
can't really give you as detailed
information on that and I know that the
applicant has a colleague who can
address issues sorry any questions in
relation to viability but certainly I
can say that we've had that looked at in
detail by independent assessment working
on our behalf
counts the field
thank you just on that look on that
point I I thought there was some
agreement that committees would see
viability assessments and as we progress
forward but my question is really around
noise I think there is a condition that
just says noise it's unclear to me just
what that's controlling and I'm looking
at page 2 1 RS and there is considerable
analysis they're talking about 60 d DB
and 55 DB a noise levels of noise and it
says somewhere if the acoustics
assessment is not submitted and the
levels can't be met then I would
recommend refusal I just wondered just
what status we are on that because I'm
not sure that I noticed it as I read the
papers certainly when the application
first came in there was an issue in
relation to noise nuisance and primarily
the disruption that residents in the
block furthest to the south my
experience from road noise
so we requested a noise assessment which
was carried out and following on from
that we consulted the environmental
control environment a health officer
responsibility for noise and he's now
advised that he's comfortable with that
subject to the imposition of conditions
i recording discussions about other
buildings in this general location and
their approval there was always
considerable concern about railway noise
and they thought that various diesel
engines and things tend to sit around in
that area of running their motors all
day long so is that be considered as
well and perhaps these buildings are
further or why I don't know I so i'll
suspect that the the noise assessment
that was carried out following on from
the concerns expressed originally would
have to take into account
know it sources that arise in the area
not just the road but as you say the
railway station as well so I think all
of those would have been factored in as
part of that and considered which led to
the conditional controls and about D B's
and things as you you know for the
living environment within the building's
themselves I'd sorry I just I don't know
if this helps at all but um in my long
career here I was also the case officer
for the people caught development which
is directly opposite the railway station
in stern market and of course that had
similar noise conditions applied on the
basis that that was immediately where
all the cars lined up to go over the
crossing and that had diesel and
everything else that the various lobbies
waiting there while waiting for the
train get to go past and we you know we
did go through that noise issue in that
local area and we apply similar
conditions but but I'm not aware that
we've got any complaints obviously been
built and occupied for some time now
but I'm not aware that they've not been
unsuccessful they've done their job so I
would be confident that similar
provisions which is what appears to be
the case here would would be equally
adequate in my opinion but that's what
you burn you're next thank you very much
chair I've also had questions about
electric vehicle charging points and
cycle storage because there's no where
RT on the on the M outline both other or
the drawings showing where the cycle
storage would be um and just to ensure
that that is in place and also I've just
got a question on SIL is whether the
there's a big payment for education but
obviously it from a care home and that's
going to be not many people going to
school from that site and from the
apartment sites for less likely as well
so I don't know whether it's if officers
can advise whether there's any
possibility of putting more money
towards the NHS than Educare
from a SIL perspective and thirdly could
you just confirm what the treatment of
the footpath is because I'm not quite
clear what the applicant is planning to
do along the footpath at adjacent to the
side if you could just confirm that
conditions about thank you John's just
going to come in on sir
good question we going to need a
five-minute break because yeah five
minutes no come back
you
we're going to continue and is everyone
here yep so we're going to continue and
based on Rachel's question we can now
answer it but apologize for that and you
may need to ask the question again but
in just while you were talking I had a
sudden realization or fear that we may
have missed something as it was an
allocated site many of the allocated
sites within stone market error action
plan are deemed to be to teach science
and as such would be zero as far as
silliest and cylinder the station
quarter allocation which is what we're
talking about here in part is not one of
those strategic sites so therefore it is
subject to community infrastructure levy
in the normal way that most other sites
are I apologize it was just one of those
things you would think oh did we miss
this and we needed to double check for
so long so false alarm in effect I have
got here the formal document that tells
me exactly which ones are subject to
being zero as far as civil is concerned
station quarter is not one of those so
going back to the obligations and so on
in terms of page 160 There is obviously
potential funding bid from Suffolk
County Council and others NHS is one of
those and that would be part of the
legislation in terms of the seal bids
that would happen beyond our beyond
planning so these are potentially the
amount that both Suffolk County Council
and the NHS may seek in respect to this
development and their bid for sale but
it is not something we sought to get you
gain on a 106 agreement because
ultimately we would be double dipping
but equally it is not necessary to do so
on the basis that the the seal charge is
in place on the basis
how the figures are set because Rachel
said can we move one to the other but
that's not for us to do is it
these figures are potential sums to be
sought by those interested parties I've
seen Suffolk County Council or the NHS
they are not for us to judge here and
equally they may change it may not be
what he's actually put in as a bid by
those parties and we don't know what the
council in charge of the pot of money
would actually grant that's a separate
procedure and and legislation
arrangement between the District Council
better safe than sorry yeah trying to
come back
Thank you very yeah thank thanks for
that answer to that question and I just
wonder if you can one of the officers
could answer the questions with regards
do I mentioned electric vehicle and what
charging points and cycle storage not
being not shown on the map and also what
the treatment for the footpath is that's
within the red line of the site and
whether that includes further trees
because I notice it's lots of comments
about remove trees but I'm not clear
from the presentation what the actual
treatment will be on the edge of that
footpath on the edge of the summit on
the river thank you
just I'm gonna put myself out here a
little bit because I think in the
comments in the questions so far there's
been a number of questions around
conditions so let me just summarize this
the proposal as of your paper 161 162
with the correction that it's 18 months
not one year and I've been picking up a
few conditions which I would be happier
that's we're not we're not into debate
but I I'm have the applicants speak yeah
okay well there are conditions if
members so wished to impose that I would
I wouldn't have a problem with in my
professional opinion here you've picked
up on electric charging that has been
applied as a condition on pre
applications and see no reason why that
wouldn't be a case here the cycle
storage given the questions about that
if you were looking to impose a
condition to say a scheme recycle
storage to the standards to be secured I
would see no reason why that could not
be done and I would also pick up on the
sprinkler question as well if you wanted
to in your debate but I'm just happy to
ask questions in this dish cancer Katya
next yes very quickly as well again
there's been no I had read us before but
it's nothing to regard Sola mentioned on
with it
Epstein we should for very large for the
care home would be quite appropriate
also there was no mention of a emergency
vehicle parking space which I believe
was standard for care homes to actually
allow for provision for and and so Stan
was actually be parked where it's not on
the plan sir sorry cat so I heard your
comment about the vehicle er emergency
vehicle parking space I think that
within the design of the layout of the
care home and the way the site works
there sufficient room if there was to be
a dedicated space for emergency vehicles
I think that could be provided quite
comfortably I missed the first part of
yes I did the sustainability issue would
that be this sorry the solar panel
element of it would be combined within
the sustainability overall
sustainability approach for both
elements of the development so the
residential and the care home it's not
something that we would specifically say
you know we don't want C on there
whatever reason it's just getting those
details on the building as you'd have
noticed it was a contemporary structure
with flat roofs so be quite easy to
actually you know provide something on
that structure and that's a covered
under bullet points on page 162 bullet
point for a bullet point under three two
three three I guess
okay touch them what are you annexed
yeah
councilman saw you were nervous thank
you my questions that actually arise
from comments made to the previous
question from calorie burn about the
sill we've got the request we asks from
the major infrastructure providers on
the on the piece on our page 160 that's
true I would just like to ask this is a
full application I know there are things
that make some things exempt from CIL
but do we have an estimate of the SIL
chargeable and the other comment I'd
like to a question I'd like to ask about
the suggestion of a condition on the
cycle storage provision I did notice
that the designer might calling a person
and you come back if it's a suggestion
on the thing mass unless we have I don't
have a calculation to what the total SIL
amount would be it's based on floor area
it's based on the charging zone I don't
know what that is we haven't
well we haven't got it it's not a
flexible small saying we can discuss or
change it's set in stone it's not for us
to debate change vote on agree yeah we
haven't got it as I said Cass reburn
thank thank cherish what are the odds to
my previous question about the treatment
of the footpath along the site and what
I'm not clear was proposed that's within
the applicants boundaries the proposal
includes a link between the footpath on
the Riverside and Prentiss Road the
actual treat of that the hard surfacing
of that would be a detail that we'd look
to secure through the condition a
general landscaping condition the
treatment of the paths either side the
sorry the foot the the Riverside path is
unchanged from what you saw in those
photographs because it obviously it's
outside of the planning application red
line site
again page 162 bullet point 1/2 3/4
bullet point 6
ok I think that's all the questions yeah
so we're happy to move on
so we now move on we don't have the
parish council or the town council we
didn't have an objector or a supporter
but we have the applicant if you'd like
to come forward thank you for waiting
dan Coghlan and we have Martin Austin
Mike Brindley for questions as well I
think it can keep the three minutes
please
good afternoon chair and members of the
planning committee
I'm Darren Kaufman planning associate
bidwells supporting this planning
application is agent also got Mike
Brindley of MTC engineering and Martin
Wallace both Pathfinder development
consultants also in attendance should
you have any particular questions
concerning flood risk matters and
viability masses respectively your
officer has provided a comprehensive
synopsis of the mix geez full plan
application and the issues for you to
consider here today accordingly unlike
this fully support the broad conclusions
in the committee report the application
site is an important brownfield site
located in close proximity to stay
market train station and falls within
the stone market area action plan of
2013 and in particular station quarter
allocation the application for you has
been subject to an extensive amount of
both pre application engagement
including pre application advice from
mid Suffolk offices that has encouraged
the scale of develop before you and post
application consultation with a wide
range of statutory consultation
stakeholders as such is evolved in
response to this extensive consultation
to respond to the various competing
matters this includes revisions to the
location of the 55 unit residential
building to facilitate a place foot path
through the site and their attention to
more trees than originally composed
together with replacement planting
parking accordingly your officer
recommends approval this previously
developed brownfields site represents a
highly sustainable location crying out
to be developed and your office's report
confirms that the range of use of
proposed Accords of the policy
requirements the caring facility would
generate jobs during only construction
but also operationally and generate
significant council tax receipts in due
course the price flats as one and
two-bedroom units will provide
relatively affordable accommodation in
this location in the context of no
redeveloped proposals for the station
quarter having emerged over a number of
years this scheme offers a real
opportunity to facilitate redevelopment
as a full detailed planning application
is being can we deliver this prompt as
promptly as perhaps be possible subject
to your support today without this the
site remain a barren wasteland there are
no technical reasons preventing the
scheme from coming forward and any
mitigation required can be secured via
appropriate planning conditions county
highways have also confirmed this
position in respect of parking provision
and cycling provision
and the hirez officer was in the room
earlier today but is not now the scheme
before you has the full support your
officer and Hakeem provide much needed
care home and flat accommodation I
therefore trust that you'll be able to
support the recommendation today thank
you
thank you very much do we have questions
yes that's the sort of customer first
I'd like to go back to the issue with
noise no one's actually mentioned you've
got carbon nightclub just the other side
of Wharfside house which carries on in
Thursday's violence athletes into the
early hours of the morning there has
been considerable problems there over
the years
in your design the buildings have you
sort of taken down to cope with the
windows to try and alleviate that sort
of noise as so as has been mentioned
actually we did actually submit a noise
assessment after the application was
made and that has been fully considered
by the Rana to Health Officer and that
has also suggested various conditions to
address matters of noise from not only
the train station but also from the
surrounding roads so that has all been
and it's all satisfactory to the
environment health and mental health
officers decision the question about
security there have been 340 offences
committed in that area in between may 20
18 April 19 as detail by the police
report containing these papers can you
assure us that the buildings will be
totally secure there's a lot of
anti-social behavior drug taking that
area which is been well reported and
that is that's quite major concern in
mine
yeah I mean security is clearly a
consideration and the buildings have
been designed and the surrounding the
buildings will be designed through
planning conditions to secure that I
mean obviously what we're trying to do
is have a position whereby it's not this
site is developed which actually should
help matters as opposed to in this
barren wasteland it is at the moment so
that should hopefully address some of
those anti-social behaviour matters
which obviously are outside our control
as well
yeah yes just question really about I
didn't notice any mention of sprinkler
systems in the in your analysis and or
in the offices analysis and they are of
critical interest to far the Gators are
well aware I wonder what your position
is yeah I mean I can understand the
perspective given what's happened over
the last couple of years elsewhere as
far as that's concerned I mean those
matters I think would be governed by the
building regulations etc as opposed to
planning per se so I'd imagine that
you've recovered by that it's obviously
something we would look at we have
incorporated a number of sustainability
measures as well within the scheme and
your office's report refers to the
design access statement that is
submitted with application so if I can
just take you to the relevant page of
the report so on page 162 162 of your
report on bullet point four it does
actually refer to sustainable
construction according to the sub me to
design access statement and within that
that talks about a number of different
things so it looks at that in the matter
of the orientation of building in
relation to to allow the maximum solar
gains because most of the building
actually faces or the the accommodation
faces either south or west
so there's actually also you get so the
gain there it also talks within that
with regard to energy regards to the
efficiency of the walls and windows so
that we would look to or we would sorry
exceed the current building regulations
you Valley requirements by at least 25
percent above the current requirements
so I think it's fair to say that we've
sought to try to future-proof the scheme
similarly with regard to water and we're
looking at a requirement of Noma 105
liters per day and that includes
fittings dual flush WCS and flow
reducing aerating taxes throughout the
building and amongst other matters thank
you so do I put your question your
answers you're prepared to increase the
the to exceed building rigs for
sustainability issue
but not for issues of people's safety
you know I didn't say that I think I
think I think the point I was trying to
make make was effective you know I don't
think that's something which is
effectively is covered by the planning
legislation I think it is a building
control matter but I've got no I've got
no objection to do that being provided
thank you no that's I mean obviously the
issue one was looking at is there is
history of far in high Wireless
buildings and it is a major concern more
so than with anything else and thank you
one other issue you mentioned your
colleagues and viability is it possible
to indicate briefly what the key element
of the as the build is that prevents the
the provision of affordable housing
thank you yes um well there are a number
of issues with with this site which I
guess many of you what will know very
well in terms of abnormal costs but to
sort of run through them very quickly
the site requires polled foundations
site strip removal of topsoil which
contains hazardous material gas membrane
importing new topsoil in there are
various utility upgrades that are
required as well as extensive drainage
surface water drainage measures the the
value that we have attributed to this
site to give you some reassurance and
obviously your your consultant has
independently verified our our our
report we've attributed a value of under
two thousand four hundred pounds per
plot so the land value that we have
assumed this site generates is to call
it modest would be an understatement the
planning policy guidance gives a range
of profit levels that would be viewed as
being acceptable in normal circumstances
to developers and we have we have used
the figure a right at the bottom
that range 15% which would be very
unusual for a high density scheme of
flats where there's loss of working
capital tied up you have to build the
whole block before you can start selling
units and also very unusual on a
brownfield site so we've attempted to
present things in a way that is as as a
reasonable as possible then your
consultant hasn't reached the same
conclusion thank you for thank you thank
you very much Casa Carta that counts the
war boys
oh very ii do apologize um with regards
to the is it possible wrong those firsts
I've lost some track a fault with this
spasmosaur to apologize I said just a
simple question of the public I was
trying to find a letter the owners of
the public houses have expressed
concerns about the increased traffic
term from the site during building week
and they're building requiring
strengthening as a result of this have
you been in contact with them at all I
haven't had direct contact with them I
mean as far as traffic is concerned and
we think we've got a remember of course
that it's already a couple it's a car
park at the moment so we're not talking
about a meal use with no traffic there
is traffic that comes from this at the
moment I think it's fair to say that it
would be an increase in traffic and
ability it also depends upon when that
traffic is coming and leaving the site
and as I say Sam Harvey was here earlier
in relation to that and we have been in
a sensitive discussion with her during
the application and we have made
revisions to application and she is
entirely comfortable with the proposals
that we put forward and the mitigation
measures that we have incorporated which
also includes creating a priority system
so there is a priority system for access
into the train station and your officer
I think discuss that and outline that in
the presentation so we have we haven't
expressly spoken to them but obviously
the period for construction is a
relatively small small short period of
time and clearly if this theme or if
this site is going to be developed at
any point they would have to be accessed
by apprentice Road there is no other
access otherwise obviously the logic of
that is that effectively the site will
just remain as a sort of barren
wasteland where evermore yeah well yes I
agree
I think it shall we not go coming okay
debate
there's no agreeing with the script we
just ask just yeah it was just how
Gujarati said about the necessity of
access to the site it was just that
they've expressed concerns about the
loss of business as a result of the
construction work being carried on and
damage to the property because of heavy
vehicles going in and out of the site my
question was that we contacted them to
sort of mitigate this as a possible
problem don't think I don't think I mean
loss of business I'm not sure that
that's necessary a planning matter
ultimately if potentially actually
creating a position where there's more
people living then I would probably
argue that once it's actually
constructed potentially there could be
more business because you'll have more
residents in the vicinity of the site
thank you
can't sleep got through snacks thank you
very quickly the highways are satisfied
with the parking provision I just asked
the question how many staff would you
have at the care home I realized that
people have come in on the bus or on the
trains but not everybody will will you
have anyone overnight any workers there
overnight and and do you think it's
appropriate that there doesn't seem to
seem to be visit to car parking for a
care home of substance
we've got from recollection I think we
learn from the discussions unfortunately
the applicant app can't be here today
because of serious family matters so
that's regrettable they would normally
attend one of these meetings so we've
basically got them I think is Matt's 20
staff obviously there will be changeover
periods and there will be staff actually
overnight as well because it will be a
shift pattern operation which is
consistent with all care homes sort of
the second part of your question was is
it appropriate that there doesn't appear
to be parking facilities for visitors to
such a large care program I think as I
say we had those discussions with salmon
we talked about the way this we envisage
the care
working and the experiences that the
applicant has had from other schemes
they have done elsewhere and it was felt
to be acceptable given given the
sustainable location of the site as I
say I think it's regrettable that Sam is
naturally hearing that because he was
here earlier okay Sam doesn't come to
most it's not a requirement we have Ho
is at its meeting at or we asked them
specifically to come to the first item
calorie burn
thank you very much sure um stay market
is quite unique in in almost unique in
Suffolk in terms of being in an
industrial market town and then this
site you know in seventeen hundreds or
whatever was was industrial usage I just
wondered have you did how much did you
consider the history of the site in your
design and and linking and linking that
especially also considering the kind of
proximity to the malting run oh there's
waterside house in between but what did
you consider about the history of the
site in your design for this thank you
I mean we looked we looked at and we did
an analysis with regard to the context
and I think it's probably fair to say
that when you actually look at the
context there isn't really a consist in
architectural treatment you mentioned
obviously there's the full story sort of
vaulted building and then there's the
more historic buildings that were hidden
behind that you've got the church in the
distance but looking at it I don't think
you've really got a palette or a
particular architectural style so we
felt that and with discussions with the
local authority that this was a site
that could actually command a slightly
more contemporary building while still
retaining brick and render which you'll
see is consistent in the vicinity of the
site and we were encouraged as I
mentioned within your office's report
and also within the I think it's the
pre-application correspondence again
from the appendices we were encouraged
to look at a modern scheme and a scheme
which is of higher density and similarly
the hair
team from the Council of actually
outlined on page 149 of your report that
they're effectively is negligible harm
to the conservation or at cetera so
they've also felt that the approach
taken is appropriate oh you've got two
more questions then we've only got Casa
Carson counselor having him I realize
being treated the V with the loss of
certain trees is necessary for the
project regarding although it's
necessary would it be probably would it
be any consideration to supporting the
visto market Drive for the six percent
increase of trade we are looking for
sponsors and for tree wardens would that
be possible for them to look into I'm
really sorry we can't our settlement for
money as Nariman a possible provision
and future to look at I was also getting
a look at with the guards but care fine
I realize being multi-story with the
care home certain people are going to be
with mobility issues what is the
provision for the emergency exit for I
know it's meant to be in the building of
what but I can't see specifically how
people with wheelchairs would get out
from a top story if he okay home now as
far as as far as the spend that the
architect who's designed this building
has done a number of care home
facilities for the applicant elsewhere
and effective II know there are lifts
and other means of access or egress so
this has all been designed into the the
proposal clear would have to build me
all those requirements with regard to
building regs and self access access etc
so that has actually been considered on
the point I think just regard to the
trees is general math so if I can just
answer that and it was mentioned that
there was a late paper or because a
paper from the pickerel project in
relation to trees and when we submitted
the application we submitted it with a
our cultural impact assessment and that
involved taking out a number of trees
that that at that point your the offices
tree officer was happy with that because
they didn't felt feel the trees were of
sufficient quality etc however in
response to the pickerel project and i
and a colleague actually met the
chairman on-site and we discussed this
matter and we subsequently amended the
plant to not only incorporate an access
point through to allowed to allow better
legibility through towards the station
but we also looked to and have
incorporated and retained more of the
trees so there are trees removed but
there's more trees retained some of
those trees we haven't got control over
and there also you will be planting
we've shown there's a landscaping plan
that's been submitted with the
application and that would obviously be
controlled by our planning conditions
should be receive a resolution to grant
so we're very conscious of these things
and we have tried to accommodate all of
these various aspects as best we can
thank you very much
accounts are having em thank you at the
moment the lands basically being used as
a car park for sort of surrounding
businesses and possibly the station as
you've used the absolute minimum level
of car parking in the future where would
use they think that the visitors or the
to the to the apartments or the care
home will park in the future as the
nearest public parking and well there is
a there is a car park from recollection
regard to the station as I say it almost
comes back I think the some extent with
regard to all those discussions and our
greement with the counter priority
because clearly in an authority such as
you know baby mid Suffolk effectively
you know stay market is a sustainable
location in that context you know this
is a site and right next to the the
train station we have a number of bus
routes and that in vicinity of the sites
so you know the actual flats that are
proposed to either one or two pair
they're not large flat so you know we
have a provision of one space per flats
which
notwithstanding the figure that was
mentioned about you know the absolute
figure this is a very sustainable
location so if we can't actually look at
a lesser figure here then I do wonder
where we can and as I say I think that's
been taken on board from in those
discussions so that we have had with Sam
Harvey okay I think we're there with the
questions yeah Ron's happy okay so we'll
move on as she thank you very much we're
not gonna move on we're gonna go
straight to debate because we have not
heard from the ward member is I'm afraid
I have not had any communication from
the ward member so straight into debate
Council in the like this the chair I
must have it I actually welcome this
development the particular area
concerned if you're approaching stone
market is an absolute disgrace at the
moment and I think anything we can do to
improve that area for business the tone
is excellent my main concern though is
with the lack of parking spaces
particular visiting parking space which
several colleagues have commented about
upon this morning my other concern is
that I can see that users of the station
which are predominately users that use
that car park at the moment will be you
know trying to park in that area which
will of course be free of charge but
it's not really a planning consideration
but yes generally I am in favor this
application and I will be supporting it
customer service
thank you I - welcome it quite like the
modern design I think I think it's great
I and the fact we've got some good
environmental sustainability features on
the buildings is also a very positive
aspect to this development and whilst I
I hear the concerns about the car
parking I I don't have particular
worries about the car parking for
departments they are close enough to the
station and the public transport network
and they are any small apartments I'm a
little more concerned about the parking
for the care home because for the staff
in particular because although it's
only have a limited number of staff and
there appears to be at least one per
member of staff you know because the
very nature of care homework will be
shift patterns that won't necessarily
fit with public transport but you know
there are some constraints on the site
and they clearly have had discussions
with highways about this so I think on
the face of it it has to be acceptable
my comment that I didn't bring up
conditions earlier on somebody else
brought it up about the conditions on
this secure cycle storage I did note
that the design out crime officer or
whatever their title is did suggest that
because this is a you know a relatively
high crime area for mid Suffolk it may
not be a high crime area per se but for
mid Suffolk it probably is and they've
suggested to make sure that the security
on the cycle parking is is there and
they've also suggested CCTV in various
places and I don't know quite what they
I don't know that that's a planning
consideration but but certainly I think
there it needs to be a condition about
the security of the cycle storage
facilities but I will be supporting this
do you want me to make a proposal
I'd like the condition and post about
the psycho storage a meeting performance
then I'll propose that we could you just
how would we can John do you just want
to run through now the various
conditions that we mentioned were the
worst points you've talked about we
could condition and Sarah can say she
wants them so the moment the
recommendation is as your report with
the correction to 18 months
implementation your condition you're
talking about there would be to agree a
secure cycle storage scheme to meet
current highway standards that is
probably all I need in order to put that
forward did you want me to talk quickly
I think
you drop a listers we're talking so
that's it Sarah what Sarah thinks um you
mentioned the let's talk about a
sprinkler system then I've just been
doing a little bit of checking of the
building regulation side of things and
um it's complicated ultimately it
depends on the other aspects of
stairways how they put together fabric
and everything else so there is an
actual requirement under building
regulations for sprinkler systems there
isn't Wales but there wasn't in the UK
in England so I'll leave that one and
let you debate that maybe electric
charging was the other point I would
have no problem with electric car
charging for cars but we would have to
have a scheme to be agreed because
ultimately given the parking
arrangements it might not be possible
for all parking spaces but at least some
so I think that's reasonable to have to
be agreed to see what comes back thank
you so basically Sarah there's three
things to be added that's changed to 18
months from a year that we have secured
cycle storage agreed to meet the highway
standard and that electric charging is
instigated as appropriate yeah okay so
that's proposed by counsel Mansell
Castlefield you were next quite happy to
have a second appoint Chancellor food as
well providing we get an agreement on
sprinkler systems yeah I think we've
done it before in locations in stone
market it's clearly a major issue in our
wires buildings can we do it is not your
expensive and can we do it like this
could we do that it's a that we we would
like the sprinkler systems to be
investigated fully because apparently
you can have systems that might be
better than sprinklers so we don't want
to force spring because if there's a
cyclone schools isn't it sometimes
actually in schools it's better not to
have a sprinkler system there's a more
secure system now because we know what
children can do when they see sprinklers
allegedly
get ready children okay so that's a so
can we put the condition in that spirit
that the it's fully investigated the bet
where the sprinklers or alternative
better solution is for fire safety quite
happy and I know the chief our officer
is prepared to reduce other requirements
to accommodate the costs of such systems
and one would you know we don't want to
be in the position of the whoever
approved grain for town so we argued
against it we said it was necessary what
is it worth if you're both happy taking
the overarching theme can I suggest
maybe that we simply seek details of
emergency exit and fire protection to be
agreed okay just give me the word okay
so that's been proposed by custom on
second bicuspid does anyone else wish to
speak yes
sorry occurs that you might wish to
impose a condition that restricts the
use of the care home to account within
class c2 because there's other uses
within that use class that may or may
not be suitable for that building so it
may be prudent to include that
conditions rather I'm betting not
certain okay anyone else wish to speak
before we go to a vote no it's it as per
the recommendation that's in our papers
laid out clearly on pages 161 and 162
with the additional points that have
been raised all those in favor please
that's unanimous
thank you very much thanks everyone and
see you today before the general
election for our next meeting